foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] sake are you doing here man oh
what the [ __ ] I'm in Jersey that's why
I'm cursing a lot welcome to fat man
beyond I'm Kevin Smith and I'm Mark
Bernard hey oh
um
I am uh let me see I was making sure
that my
Instagram post was up there so folks
know that we're going live right now
we're doing it fat man beyond
um welcome kids
to the pop culture show that
shows you it knows nothing no there's a
guy on this show seems to know quite a
bit
and it always works out in the end
loves everything at all times
um welcome to the show kids it's been a
minute since we gathered together uh but
here we're doing it Mark as you can see
is uh about to fight the Highlander
there could be only one I'm reporting
from the Rebellion live on aldani is
that what it is
I was gonna I was gonna go for uh Julie
Andrews is about to sing right Beyond
because those Hills look alive with the
sound of music I as you could tell
they met Jay and Silent Bob's secret
stash behind me are two gigantic Funko
Pops of of me and Jay that when
civilization collapses and they are
Unearthed a thousand years from now
finally I will have reached my goal of
having people be like I guess they were
worshiped as gods
and from the depths of hell I'll be like
we sure were spread the word I think
Charlton Heston ship crashes and he ends
up in the underground civilization
instead of worshiping the bomb they will
worship the Bob
or or the bong either way uh we don't
think that all of us on Earth had these
giant black eyes I'll be like yes in
order to adapt to the Rays of the sun uh
after we destroyed the ozone layer we
grew a thick black mask over all of our
eyes you made a desert of it so cute
um I have been in Jersey uh for a few
days we had our first smod castle event
I was in California I did five
California shows still on the uh clerks
three the roman face mask the uh
convenience tour uh that is last week I
was in the California portion of it so
we did
San Francisco
Sacramento San Diego Los Angeles
and Anaheim then I came out here to New
Jersey
where I have the apartment over smod
Castle Cinemas my brand new movie
theater
and uh we shot a music video on Saturday
uh artist uh perhaps you've heard of by
the name of logic
oh thank you very much uh Bobby came
with his crew and we shot
uh video which essentially was like
shooting Clerk's Forks we went back to
Quick Stop and Brian was there Brian
o'holler and Jeff Anderson Jason Muse
um and had a blast man it was good ass
time I was so thankful for him he had
this idea where he's like I want to
shoot at a quick stop I was like you're
talking to the right guy logically we
could do this and so we uh we got to
hang out with a bunch of people that
made
clerks 3 as well uh there's a little
reunion of sorts it was a very busy day
because also we were shooting uh since
we've taken over spot Castle Cinemas uh
I wanted to put up uh hello and welcome
to smodcastle Cinemas you know throw
your garbage out one of those videos so
since Jay and I were already in the
costumes
we did it as Jane Silent Bob so we also
shot the in theater promo
um in front of quick stop and then
Sunday morning I shot some more stuff
inside the movie theater I rolled out of
bed walked down the stairs came
concession stand and in my robe and
started shooting uh Saturday night
I'm happy to report we did our first uh
smod Castle programming uh with a live
performance of uh Hollywood Babylon with
the great Ralph Carmen who flew out for
it and it was magnificent it's the first
time we'd ever done Babylon in Jersey
um a fantastic first run that paves the
way for you and I to do fat man beyond
out here so I'm gonna get uh Ralph going
on a bi-monthly schedule which sounds
exactly as [ __ ] sexy as I mean it so
hopefully we can get fat man beyond
going on a bi-monthly schedule as well
and you come out and we do the show
here at the theater and step one stream
it live from the theater this movie
theater has been such a smod send Mark
um it is dialing my clock back it's just
so fun there's a bunch of kids that work
there who are literally kids yeah I'm
always like the kids these kids and all
these kids hey kids you know that's
because I'm like 52 and I feel like the
oldest person there are kids that work
at spod Castle like kids that play field
hockey in high school is crazy yeah and
it's it's it's neat man they all run the
theater they don't need any help I mean
I'm going to help in as much as I'm
gonna bring more programming but it's
like something out of Little Rascals
[ __ ] adorable
um
memories what's up I just want to add I
think you called me a kid
up until like 18 months ago I was a kid
up until Batman
and I'm almost 42. so I still call you a
kid behind your back I'm like that
[ __ ] kid the one that streams the
show he's smart
uh yeah everyone I call kids part of it
I think is due mostly to
uh Chevy Chase in uh National Lampoon's
Vacation hey kids are you thirsty and
also uh you know Marty Moose when they
get to
Wally World where he's like hey kids
we're closed for two weeks to clean the
room hire America's favorite Family Fun
Park sorry I guess it says sorry folks
uh not hey kids so in any event
yeah I say it's a lot it's also a really
great way to not have to remember
anybody's name because if you establish
that you're calling hated then you never
need to remember a name just be a kid
how's it going a lot of people in the
[ __ ] 50s love it too they're like
what's up what's up kid so I'll announce
like pre fat man beyond it at the
Cantina a lot of times I'm have grown up
saying boys and girls
or men and women but I'm very careful
not to do that now so I'll either refer
to everybody in the audience as scum and
villainy or as kids because kids is a
non-gendered term
thank you JC my kid AKA Harley Quinn
Smith hit me to this very thing when she
went to one of the shows I did and you
know she's like you say ladies and
gentlemen I was like of course that's
what they say at the circus and if this
is not a circus I don't know what the
[ __ ] is
and uh she's like yeah but
and I was like oh my God you're right so
then I switched over to kids welcome
clerks three of the convenience tour
yeah
my go-to is gay hey gang how's it going
because I also used to say not even like
boys and girls or ladies and gentlemen I
would just default to guys it's like hey
guys what's up and it's like I can't do
that what a way first 10 15 years the
career was always guys and then one day
it was like oh I guess you know and I
don't mind changing I don't want to hurt
anybody's [ __ ] feelings and [ __ ] and
I don't mind including it's [ __ ]
stupid business
to not include everybody you know on a
purely [ __ ] Financial level is just
dumb to be like well I'm going to say
what I say and [ __ ] everybody else but
just on a personal level I was you know
I was raised by Grace Smith man and
death before discourtesy so the idea of
like somebody out there feeling like oh
man I had a [ __ ] Twitter exchange
with a dude that was like flat out
frightening I'm gonna read it to you
real quick
good Christ
um so it started like this
I don't know I'm not gonna give you the
name I watched every Kevin Smith movie
went to live podcast special in-person q
a screenings brought bought merch then
2016 election broke him and I heard how
much he hated me and people like me and
haven't seen anything since sucks I
really wanted to see clerks three now
Mark you've been with me since before
the 2016 election
do you ever hear me get political
rarely
rarely
and never in a I hate you sort of way
just say huh you know
it's getting weird out there it's not my
thing I don't [ __ ] trade in politics
so I've never really talking during the
20s you know all adjourned Trump's term
and [ __ ]
you know people are like you should be
mad why are you saying that John Apatow
is saying stuff that's fine that's great
Judd apto is far more educated man than
I am and I guess he pays attention to
politics but I'm a goddamn Entertainer
I'm a clown uh you know I [ __ ] make
Kevin Smith movies I'm not even an
Entertainer there I'm an Entertainer
down here people don't come to me for
like it's your [ __ ] penetrating
thought on politics and world events
they come to me for [ __ ] Comfort they
come to get away from that kind of [ __ ]
so I made it a point of never talking
really about that [ __ ] now if you're
like well I know he's pretty liberal
because you know I've seen all his
movies great you could draw your own
conjectures about where I stand on the
political Spectrum
um based on all the movies I've made
yeah I'd say
he's a Live and Let Live kind of guy and
a bleeding heart liberal of sorts but
you never see me trying to jam it down
your [ __ ] throat do you no just not
my thing so this tweet is baffling to me
so I write the 2016 election broke me uh
show me where show me all the times I
ever got political on social media if
you don't want to see clerks uh the
clerks movie no worries but don't use
Politics as an excuse because I'm not
political at all you are
then the cat writes you were on here on
your podcast too it breaks my heart that
you attack me here too you used to be a
cool dude it's sad honestly hurts me
Mark did I attack that person in the
previous tweet that I just read to you
no no no you didn't
so this fucker's off the rails by you
know I don't agree with him on tweet one
but I engage and [ __ ] and I feel like
I'm relatively polite for a dude that
out of nowhere is just like me [ __ ] in
your mouth
and then the guy says that he feels
attacked what the [ __ ] so I write how
was my response to your Tweet and attack
between this tweet and your original
tweet I responded to uh where's anything
you could possibly be hurt by this is
honestly baffling and again cite
examples of me getting political links
or it didn't happen so he puts this post
he you went from this and it said good
morning don't forget to vote today
doesn't matter who you vote for just
exercise your constitutional right to
vote at all because if you don't vote
then you can't [ __ ] about the results
and throwing [ __ ] at how people voted is
about as American As baseball and apple
pie I guess that was my tweet in night
in 2016. then he wrote to this a video
literally comparing Trump to Thanos and
bite into the adventures Kevin Smith
isn't political on Twitter not at all
sucks truly he posted this [ __ ] tweet
that I retweeted from somebody I think
it was the [ __ ] Russo Brothers
where they put up this video you know of
the [ __ ] speech at the end of
Avengers and [ __ ] and all I wrote was
one week from today assemble voting is
the end game and I wrote in parentheses
help me give credit to whoever made this
I got it from a follower who also
doesn't know anybody have any idea where
this marvelous piece of editing came
from hashtag vote that sound remotely
political to you mark does it sound like
me telling you to vote for and [ __ ] even
if that video
you know a [ __ ] clearly uh leans one
way more than the other
do you consider that meet the 2016
election breaking me and me telling
people and people like him I hate him
like this cat is such a [ __ ] clown so
I write so a video I didn't make but
simply retweeted along with a similar
non-partisan vote message as the sample
you retweeted is the only remotely
political posting of mine that you could
find and somehow you're still mad and
this is how it ends ready
congrats man I went from lamenting the
loss of feeling welcomed by a Creator I
admired and respected now I [ __ ] hate
you
thank you
holy [ __ ] the kids are not all right
Mark you're a petulant ungrateful bully
child now I want to take you back to the
first tweet which came from a petulant
unruly bully child who said out of
nowhere I Prevail of nothing asked by
nobody I watched every Kevin Smith movie
went to live podcast special in-person q
a streams bought merch then 2016
election broke him and I heard how much
he hated me and people like me and I
hadn't seen anything because it sucks I
really wanted to see clerks three
I consider that petulant bully childing
especially when it's patently [ __ ]
untrue
um
that's for turning out worse than I hope
thanks I guess he spelled that wrong
thanks for turning out worse than I hope
you're a monster
[ __ ] you now I'm not gonna bother
rereading the three tweets that I read
but Mark do you hear did you hear
anything monstrous in those tweets well
I it it's monstrous in the way that
Sully is a monster in Monsters Inc cute
and and [ __ ] huggable right and a
little in a little baffled by it all
what's happening here that that [ __ ]
destroyed me this morning man like I'm
like
you can't win people just love to make
up a story and [ __ ] stick with it
even when the person they're talking
about is like you know you know nothing
of my work
dude just like why are you attacking me
and it's like you [ __ ] attacked me
all I did was respond like
[ __ ] around and find out if you don't
want done don't start none don't start
none there won't be none but I didn't
even like give back Venom I wasn't even
like let me knock this [ __ ] down a pig
literally asked questions uh baffling
everything of my life Mark some bizarre
exchange like that or a lot since 1995
I've been on these internets
people are [ __ ] weird but I will say
this they're getting sillier like in as
much as like people will just make up a
story there was a cat like who tweeted
the other day it was like there was a
link to some [ __ ] story where I was
like uh I would never direct a Marvel or
Disney thing directing a Marvel Disney
thing is a Fool's Aaron says Kevin Smith
guy was like 100 he's pitched his
terrible ideas to Disney and Star Wars
and they've said no and you can fact
check that very easily I wrote 100 I've
never pitched anything to Disney or Star
Wars atrocious or bad or otherwise
whatever [ __ ] he said and then somebody
was like you need Howard the Duck once
and I was like number one we didn't do
Howard the Duck number two I didn't
pitch that [ __ ] Jeff invited me in
and said do you want this job same thing
with Masters the Universe I didn't pitch
that either uh that Rob was like hey do
you want this job and I was like yeah
absolutely so no I've never [ __ ] pit
100
I've never pitched like it's just so
crazy like [ __ ] like think they
know the truth and [ __ ] and it's like I
know me a hundred percent I know me a
hundred percent you don't know me at all
I'm a [ __ ] conjecture to you I'm a
concept I'm not even a human [ __ ]
being anymore I'm a name on the internet
that you can like throw around whatever
information you want about be like 100
he [ __ ] pitched [ __ ] that nobody
likes like no you can literally [ __ ]
follow my long tail across the internet
since before most of these [ __ ] were
born and find out that I've never wanted
to make a [ __ ] Star Wars movie or a
Marvel movie or DC movie and [ __ ] I've
always wanted to make Kevin Smith movies
so
ooh the internet Mark hot take the
internet can be unfair
indeed and it very much seems now more
than ever that certain people want to be
victims of a thing
and then they decide who's the
victimizer whether it's true or not and
you just happen to be the handy lever
for this guy I'm assuming it's a guy to
find a way to be hurt by the internet
because apparently you broke him
he called me a Monster
based on those three tweets that I read
aloud like
so somebody in chat was like man why do
you pay attention to negative people you
got to pay attention to positive you're
absolutely right and I do pay attention
to the positive people uh in real life
but I engage uh with the negative people
because I if I don't
you know I'll lose my mind because some
of them are just absolutely baffled me
where I'm like do they believe that is
that
why do they think that's true and even
if you'd give them the correct
information even if the information
comes from the horse's mouth they're
like nope that ain't true you're like
all right
well I'm a wasting my [ __ ] time
um anyway Saturday night we did Babylon
so that means we will you and I will be
doing fat man beyond when do you think
you're gonna come to to the east not in
my mouth
um
that's the first question though that's
that's what we're thinking about
exactly give us a thought get back to me
on the next show
I'm a monster I'm a monster in the sack
Mark I'm a monster at sucking dick that
guy got it half right it's it's hard to
be a monster in one part of your life
than not a monster in all of it so I'm
assuming that you just have a monstrous
appetite and I'm assuming you got a
Celsius can [ __ ] so let me just show you
100 Mark let me show you 100 really is
I might have dislocated my jaw hopefully
you're smaller than a Celsius
hello Mr dentist here's what happened
[ __ ] my friend Scott
me having my jaw wired shut that's my
horror movie that's me not being able to
express myself to talk
to be like people were mean to me on the
internet how will I live
um you know what's really funny whenever
I respond to somebody who attacks me
then there's always some clown who's
like
why who's the bigger idiot the one the
Tweet or the one who went out of his way
to respond to the tweet
I'm like well the biggest idiot is the
one who just wrote this [ __ ] tweet
like you got no dog in this fight and so
if somebody engages me on the internet
like why am I supposed to just be like
you're right say your untruthful piece
and I will just sit here and take it
like no it's no crazy that people like
you're not playing by the rules
with answering me with facts yes
yes oh my God you know
one day
this escaping [ __ ] wound that's
within me that cries out for validation
from total strangers
will be healed mark
and when that day comes I will not be on
the internet a single moment longer now
I've been trying to heal that wound for
oh 52 years so I can't imagine it's
gonna be healed anytime [ __ ] soon but
just like that good Christ if only I was
a whole complete person then I I
wouldn't need to be on social media or
if I didn't have [ __ ] to sell if I was
[ __ ] Affleck famous where you just do
[ __ ] you're you know [ __ ] it sells
anyway then I wouldn't have to like sing
for my supper and hustle and [ __ ]
take [ __ ] from strangers on the internet
who are like you bad at what you do and
I'm like I'm the only one who does what
I do and they're like and that's bad
foreign
and then when I'm like hey I I disagree
then they're like you're not allowed to
say anything you're a [ __ ] character
yeah see that's I suppose it's a it's a
mercy that you and I have a different
relationship with the internet
um because I I similarly don't get into
it that often with people who have
negative things to say about me
but what I do I am rarely polite about
it
um and I am rarely
um particularly engaging you're you're
I've seen your [ __ ] off you're a real
[ __ ] like I'm gonna be like you know I
was called a petulant [ __ ] bully or
some says [ __ ] but I you know I'm just
kind of dry I'll try to go for the Oscar
Wilde approach like very witty wild very
witty but your [ __ ] No Holds Barred
you're like look at this racist
I'm very I get very oh my God
exactly you have to pull somebody out
into the Town Square and maybe shoot
them in the back of the head to remind
everybody that Omar's and there are a
bunch of tweets being launched at the
same time going Omar coming but
but like you know asterisk whistles
what was it the the farmers
what's up bamf man are you guys
reference in The Wire when I was a kid
of the wire I I was just gonna say
Mark's not selling enough be humble but
let [ __ ] know T-shirts if he
was paying his rent with those t-shirts
he would be a lot quieter on the
internet like I am it's true exactly
there's a guy who's trying to put asses
and seats on clerks three the
convenience store tickets at
clerks3.movie kids we're going to
Toronto tomorrow night that's sold out
but they added a second show their
tickets left for that somebody tweeted
me right before the show they were like
can't sell out a single show and I
texted him a [ __ ] phone tweeted him a
photo of all the sold out shows it's
like this information is easily checked
like if you're gonna launch a [ __ ]
attack just check your phone
anything
uh yes it's crazy crazy I'm pretty sure
that if if anybody can be uh accused of
being overly political on this show it's
probably me
um so I'm sorry for [ __ ] up your Vibe
Kev if if the political spill is heading
over your direction but if that person
is talking about you or Ralph like when
Ralph does a trump impression with his
fans and [ __ ] that ain't [ __ ] me and
also like not for nothing
like we would have Ralph would have made
fun of any president like that's part of
[ __ ] comedy the lowest hanging fruit
is like who's in charge make fun of that
[ __ ] and stuff okay yeah it's not
[ __ ] exactly Pancho
ugh
but it's just I I've gone out of my way
not to be political so it always
irritates me when somebody's just like
oh you're so political I'm like no I'm
not in the least sexually political
perhaps
it's a vote here everybody gets a vote
you know what else we did on Saturday
night I had a full day Saturday night I
shot the music video shot the promo for
the theater did a full ass Babylon to a
sold out show and then [ __ ] screen
tusk foreign
oh my God it was awesome
um let me tell you what's coming up man
I was just texting today coming up at
smodcast Castle Cinemas the next event
that we're doing is
um on November 2nd
uh Curious George an evening with George
R.R Martin oh I like the name thank you
um and he I asked I said what do you
want to talk about he goes I'm on a book
tour so by the time I get to you the
last thing in the world I'm going to
want to talk about is [ __ ] Game of
Thrones so can we talk about comic books
can we talk about movies can we talk
about TV can we talk about Jersey can we
talk about writing I was like
[ __ ] you are speaking my
language he is so awesome I met him at
new chatel as a film festival in
Switzerland and he was the dude I've
told the story here many times he was
like you know if you look at Avengers
issue two or three I think it's three
maybe four
there's a letter from him in the back
complimenting Lee and [ __ ] the the
staff and [ __ ] saying like this is
strong adult writing and I appreciate
where you're taking these characters and
stuff this guy's got [ __ ] Rich geek
history he was there when they laid the
track of fandom he also told me he was
like once he put that letter was
published in Avengers somebody reached
out to him and he was like hey man I saw
you live in Bayonne I live [ __ ]
nearby
I love this book too do you ever want to
hang out and talk comics and he's like
so we met in the real world and we would
talk about comics and we would trade
comics and then we met others like that
and then we all decided like well let's
bring our Comics to a place and trade
them and sell them they created the
first [ __ ] comic book convention like
this guy
I know he you know [ __ ] created the
Red Wedding and all that [ __ ] but like
he's [ __ ] fascinating and so
entertaining so George Curious George
kids an evening with George R.R Martin
gonna happen on November 2nd a smodcast
castle Cinemas next event I know we're
going to do is on Black Friday we're
going to show Zach and Miriam Make a
Porno I'm going to host a screening of
that
um because we got the Craig Robinson
Black Friday joke in that movie that
movie takes place on [ __ ]
Thanksgiving so I'm like there it is for
Thanksgiving
pretty sure we're putting it together I
think we're going to do A Charlie Brown
Thanksgiving so we're going to serve
popcorn toast jelly beans
and show a Peanuts movie of my choosing
preferably
um Snoopy Come Home the saddest oh my
God
I mean that's the day to rip people's
hearts out on Thanksgiving make you
[ __ ] thankful that you're you're not
Snoopy looking for Lila spoiled
so that's what's coming up spot because
I'm loving this I'm [ __ ] loving this
and if you hate me you should love that
I love this because let me tell you
something exhibiting movies is going to
take me away from [ __ ] making movies
there you go
um I could give you an update on the
movie business please do I don't know
what did Where What Where but the
highest grossing film uh in our theater
was smile
and on Friday night now mind you Friday
night is like
when I was a kid you couldn't get a seat
in the big theater on a Friday night and
granted smile was in its second weekend
but
smile had like 23 people on 7 30 on a
[ __ ] Friday or seven o'clock on a
Friday
Amsterdam
um which just opened David O Russell
movie you know never more than five
people at any given show so as a movie
exhibitor mark
no
um they picked the wrong time to get in
the movie business
thank God I got Luck cast oh my God
uh no it's crazy there was a let me see
last
is it last night I mean granted it's a
Sunday night and [ __ ] but seven o'clock
show of la la crocodile
nobody was there I walked in placed
[ __ ] empty sat down watched 10
minutes a lot of crocodile
um did you understand why it was empty
well I mean it's kids movie playing at
night and [ __ ] ain't nobody like let's
get [ __ ] up and see La wow crocodile
although if I was gonna get [ __ ] up
maybe that's the movie
um Josh and Liv you know I'm on tour
with them they're the tour managers
right so they're
um they when I'm down they're down so
they were here in Jersey for the shoot
and and uh also to shoot the smog Castle
intro and stuff so you know we were
talking on the road at one point we were
in Oregon doing shows Salem Oregon and I
was talking about Gus vonset and uh you
know I was like oh man it's like
Drugstore Cowboy and like we've never
seen that I was like how the [ __ ] do you
not see Drugstore Cowboy I said so
we gotta we gotta watch if you're gonna
watch I wanna watch it with you and then
I was like wait a second if we're gonna
watch it at all
let's watch it downstairs in my
[ __ ] monkey theater
so Josh hooked it up we watched uh
um Drugstore Cowboy last night it was
[ __ ] dope man like oh my God I was
sitting there in my pajamas my feet over
the sea [ __ ] eating a bunch of fake
Meats unreal Deli Jenny gold Farms
unreal Deli drinking [ __ ] all the
Celsius I brought with me into the
[ __ ] theater not a free address I
like it it's good
um oh it was [ __ ] bliss bliss and
yeah I'll admit it smoking [ __ ] weed
yes there I said it
oh how did you say that out loud
um and it was fantastic now
we also watched another thing oh here's
Batman can I ask you a question yes uh
Tusk came out in 2014.
did you and you didn't we didn't tour it
there was no Tusk tour it was an a24
which have you whichever
have you ever watched that movie with
people in a theater outside of the
premiere and if this was the first time
what it got eight years later which I
can't believe eight years later
how was it like did it play different I
watched Tusk with a couple audiences the
premiere uh the Toronto Film Festival
screening which was absolutely [ __ ]
magical Standing Ovation
um
and then I saw it uh at Fantastic Fest
in Austin which was weird because there
were a bunch of journalists there
that were in lockstep with this one guy
who uh was like the biggest Kevin Smith
hater on the planet I forget his name
but he would go after me like all the
[ __ ] Devin ferrachi that was his name
he would go after me like constant me
and uh
and what's her name
um Lexi Alexander like it was crazy you
go look it up Devin franchi Kevin Smith
like he would write these insanely
detailed hate pieces
um so he was involved with uh fantastic
Fest and the year we went like you know
the guy who runs the Fest what's his
name um
Tim Lee who's wonderful I've known Tim
forever and [ __ ] like when we did the
Rolling Road Show here in New Jersey
they showed clerks outside in uh the
park here in Red Bank and stuff
um I've known him for years and stuff
but that that guy he brought that guy
into his organization and that guy like
hated my [ __ ] guts for whatever
reason and [ __ ] he got me too or
something like that if I remember
correctly somebody came out said he did
some [ __ ] I don't know but suddenly he
disappeared used to write for birth
death movies I think it was fun so that
screening of Tusk and sorry I had to go
through all that to explain this that
screening of tusk was incredibly not
satisfying because there was a front row
of of Texas film people you know that
wrote for birth death movies and and
another one I forget the other one down
there Film School Rejects and stuff and
uh you know people still didn't like me
because like you know I got mouthy with
critics at one point and so throughout
this whole [ __ ] movie and this is a
weird ass movie I'm not saying
everybody's gotta like it but it's
perfect for fantastic Fest
there was a bunch of people enjoyed it
but the front row was a wall of this
so that screening was you know memorable
for how [ __ ] like stoic the front row
was unnecessarily so uh so to answer
your question JC
it's been a long time since I've seen
Tusk in a theater and we had like
believe it or not at midnight on
Saturday night we had a hundred and
145 paid customers so that's you know
[ __ ] pretty legit
um you know honestly that's more than
Amsterdam had all weekend so
the Atlantic Highlands you know what I'm
gonna start doing keeping track of the
box office at my movie theater and [ __ ]
because you know like the top five on
Mondays and [ __ ] because we would have
been the highest grossing film of the
weekend Tusk number one
Castle Cinemas
um
so it was that was a great screening so
much so that like I'm like oh I can't
wait to show yoga but first I think the
next one's gonna be uh Zach and Mary
Make a Porno because of the Thanksgiving
theme so oh my God it's it's fun man and
Mark's gonna
come out and do Streets of Fire hell
yeah I'm putting together a whole list a
week The Ides of Mark it's a week in
March
I love that oh in March that's when
you're thinking about yeah that's when
the Ides of March are they're the middle
week of March
this thing writes itself
honestly I love I love programming this
theater
so much it's [ __ ] sick if you hate me
and you're like I hate Kevin Smith then
figure out a way to ruin this for me
because I love it so much like this it's
so this is the life I would have led if
I could have if I wasn't a filmmaker but
let's be honest if I wasn't a filmmaker
I would have never been able to buy a
[ __ ] movie theater with my friends
um I would have needed a lot more
[ __ ] friends and um it's just [ __ ]
Bliss man what a thing that happened at
age 52.
um Jason Muse was there this weekend of
course and his big he came up to the
apartment and the movie theater and his
big uh suggestion was a fireman's Pole
from my apartment
to the theater
I was like but then there's a big hole
up into my [ __ ] theater in my house
and he's like well you can put a cover
over it and I was like then what's how
it'll take me less time to just walk
down the stairs he's like well the
elevator takes a walk so I got an
elevator and I was like well you don't
have to use the elevator you could
literally walk down the stairs and go
through the concession stand he's like
but a [ __ ] fireman's pole and I'm
like
dude this ain't Ghostbusters
see I just look forward to like five
years from now six years from now when
you just get so homey in there that you
will just walk out of your apartment
through the concession stand in the
middle of like Friday Night Rush when
[ __ ] like Ant-Man Quantum 80 is
playing or whatever the [ __ ] you're
just like oh there's Kevin Smith and his
robe and his will be slippers you know
going into the movie theater like the
ghost of this mod Castle Cinema bet on
Amazing bet on it because one of our you
know we do a bunch of programming one of
our programs is the merry Marvel movie
Society where you [ __ ] join up and
you see
first run Marvel movies with the [ __ ]
biggest Marvel fan in in the smodcast
castle Cinemas himself mark
[Laughter]
um I loved Marvel so much I've pitched
atrocious terrible things so many times
and they've said no one of those times
100 mark 100 percent
um yeah man I'm telling you the smart
Castle Cinemas is [ __ ] dope
um so I can't wait Ides of Mark [ __ ]
that's good I'm doing a film festival
for Josh Roush called rauschaman the
film
um I came up with full you want to hear
the other programs I'm going to do yeah
all right hold on
um
God damn it where did I put my list
well let's talk about something else
with time then yeah I was busy writing
down my list for that I'll throw out
what we're gonna do at scum and villainy
and maybe you can please do maybe you
can pick it down you know Rocky Horror
Picture Show is a huge thing but that's
nice we're gonna do it we're not really
a rocky horror I mean I guess we are but
that's I've never done that it's not my
thing so we're going to do uh
uh once in a while screening called
anybody want a peanut and it's going to
be the princess bride done like Rocky
Horror and so you'll come in and you'll
sign up to play a character and we'll
show the movie with the subtitles on
and at different points throughout the
the audience will say the lines of
dialogue along with the movie and then
you know anytime fezik Rhymes will give
people little bags of peanuts to throw
and uh and and make it fully interactive
so we're going to do that with Princess
Bride
that is brilliant
perfect it bring it to smodcast Castle
okay
we could do scum and villainy cantina
presents does anybody want a peanut that
would play [ __ ] huge man uh that
Merry Marvel movie Society will include
the TV shows kids so if you're in the
area and you join
then we'll watch the TV shows as well
now you're like you can't charge for
that I won't
you'll pay for popcorn though I'll tell
you that much
yes
um because that's what the movie Biz is
when you're a movie exhibitor The
Swedish Plum is not the box office cut
that's tiny
that's like just the tip and [ __ ] the
only way you pay the bills is by selling
[ __ ] candy and [ __ ] so
you should make Memorial memoriam
whatever commemorative popcorn buckets
in the shape of the Kevin Smith head
behind you so that you can sit there and
in 20 bucks or just take home that
[ __ ] big ass Kevin Smith head and
people can come back fill it up with
popcorn go home
so then you can hit him hard for the
movies you can't charge it for I love
the way you think we're in the process
of doing popcorn buckets a little
cheaper than [ __ ] plastic heads and
[ __ ] we'll get there one day though I
promise but right now we're going to do
customized cups and popcorn buckets and
[ __ ] so if you come and get them it's
worth keeping take home and [ __ ] like
collect them all and whatnot and also
gives us a chance to Showcase artists
like [ __ ] dark Nate returns [ __ ]
you know the weights you see is
Marquee in the lobby I'm sorry we're
just killing time [ __ ] talking about
this but obviously you can tell I'm
excited can I let me just read the
[ __ ] programs we're gonna do and then
we'll move on this is like so far Brat
Pack Attack the films of John Hughes
directly responsible face to face with
filmmakers at smodcast so that's going
to be the Russo Brothers they're coming
in it's March or able when they're done
shooting their movie they were going to
come in December but then Joe was like
can we wait till we're done with the
movie house absolutely
Um Zack Snyder is coming in the new year
and he's like I've never shown Justice
League in a theater once I was like
brother
bring it so he'll be part of that series
Jason Reitman and stuff so that's the
series where the famous directors come
directly responsible face to face the
filmmakers of smart Castle then how
about this [ __ ] Sure Shot movies
made in Jersey
on the waterfront is one of those
[ __ ] pictures
um the movies that made me with Kevin
Smith so that means I show you all the
movies that I love that made me meet and
mind you these are all like series that
we run throughout the year
like monthly weekly whatever the [ __ ] uh
rock out with your dock out
the movies of Malcolm Ingram
so we do all Malcolm's movies a week of
Malcolm's movies The Ides of Mark
a week with Mark Bernardin
and I spelled it w-e-a-k
um makes sense smod Castle Sunday
morning mass and pancake breakfast
that's where we show Dogma every every
every month
um
clerks open all night that's the
all-night clerks Marathon from Midnight
until six in the morning concluding with
a quick stop breakfast
and two's Askew man uh Tuesdays every
Tuesday night enter the ask Universe we
just roll the you know clerks through
clerks three consecutively and then
start all over and stuff
um how Fun's that [ __ ] sound
that's pretty dope you know what I'm
saying I don't dial a motherfucker's
clock back and [ __ ] like that if I ever
have a heart attack again it's gonna be
because I'm like I'm having too much fun
it's mod Castle you know and that's a
good one so in any event and nobody
tuned in to hear about that but that's
what's going on kids that's what's going
on in my world now I'm going back on the
road I got Toronto Toronto clerks three
the convenience tour resumes tomorrow
Toronto Toronto Ottawa first Toronto
sold out second Toronto is the flow of
you know rollover show we added it after
the first show sold out so that's like
not sold out but half sold over half
sold at this point the uh next night is
Ottawa that sold out the night after
that Grand Rapids Michigan sold out then
we go to Detroit to Fillmore where we've
done fat man beyond indeed uh not sold
out but 1400 people [ __ ] strong so no
complaints there uh then we go to
Montreal
yeah Beck uh which is not nearly sold
out so if you're in Montreal kids if
you're in Quebec
clerks3.movie and then I come back to
Jersey because I go do the Good Morning
America
like on one of those days and then I go
back to Atlanta
Orlando Tampa Nashville the tour rolls
on the convenience store we are at show
22
of 51. so
halfway not even still a ways to go and
it's gonna be sad when it's all over
because every night it's just love and
Bliss and [ __ ]
um so come on out kids clerks3 dot move
that's enough about me selling my [ __ ]
we probably have to sell other [ __ ] to
stay on the air am I correct Mark we do
indeed my friend
this episode of fat man beyond is
brought to you by the good Folks at the
native
deodorate that's right kids native
makes it so you don't stick
I had to get some products
for this apartment here and not here I'm
pointing like I'm there but in Atlantic
Highlands over the movie theater that's
where I live so I had nothing there I
didn't bring anything so I had to go out
and get some products I went to CVS what
do you think I got
you got yourself some body wash I got
body wash I got [ __ ] deodorant and
[ __ ] I want I went native Mark I don't
know
and they were like look at you you got
you got class you got style I was like
that's right because I'm going native
Native kids uh smell and feel fresh all
day long with Native get 20 off your
first order by going to nativedeo.com
Fatman or use the promo code fat man all
one word at checkout that's native d e
o.com Fatman or use a promo code Fatman
at checkout for 20 off your first order
native is an amazing product because
aluminum free deodorant keeps their
ingredients list bare naked with
ingredients you understand like coconut
oil shea butter and baking soda they
check a lot of boxes 72 hour odor
protection naturally derived ingredients
and a smooth residue free application
native also offers a variety of scents
my favorite being candy cane with
holidays coming up smell like a [ __ ]
candy cane with new limited edition sets
being released on the time and if you
got any sense whatsoever you'll get your
hands on some [ __ ] native take us
home mark
and when you use native you'll smell
amazing all day long tanks they're long
lasting scents spicy and woodsy clean
and fresh they got a scent option for
everyone including like warm cider and
cinnamon cashmere and Rain toasted
marshmallow and vanilla Wildwood and
cardamom
that sounds delicious so Now's the Time
to make the switch from antiperspirant
to Native
when you visit this site you can
discover all their first scents maybe
even try out one of their body washes
play Red I like the sugar cookie because
I smell like a sugar cookie
um
somebody on Twitter just rocked My World
Eric Reynolds says Kevin the Hat flipped
under the chin is perfect Tusk
merchandise let's see
Maybe
you know
good point it's not wrong
maybe what I need to do is you get like
a brown cap
and then you attach the tusks
like thusly
so they go they go down that up yeah
you know what
I like the way you [ __ ] think good
job Eric Reynolds yeah way to be Eric
Reynolds so yeah smell and feel fresh
all day long with Native get 20 off your
first order by going to nativedeo.com
Batman or use promo code Fatman at
checkout that's
nativedeo.com Fatman or he's promo code
Fatman at checkout for 20 off your first
order we thank the good folks of the
Native d-e-o
we do we love the native folks because
they seem to like us
um and we like anyone that likes us oh
yeah uh there it is kids go to
nativedeo.com Fatman and show them some
[ __ ] love
smell pretty with Native deo.com all
right let me tell you something about Mr
Mark Bernard man not only is a foreign
[ __ ] writer but years ago before you
know him and [ __ ] when you were coming
your daddy's nut sack Mr Mark Bernardin
was covering the [ __ ] news and that
never dies kids Never Dies so before we
get into reviews let's get to the news
with Mr Mark but our no good news is
good good news says Gary
uh so hey you know Alan Moore right uh
comic book writer extraordinaire Alan
Moore I'm familiar with the man's genius
work but I don't I've never met him of
course I'm sure he wouldn't really uh
you know what I don't know but I doubt
he'd care for me or my work and stuff
but he seems like a nice guy you know as
as far as LJ's Wizards go I think he
seems very uh very positively cuddly he
uh I kind of do a little bit of what I
do because he did what he did I loved
his writing so much I was like oh I want
to write comic books and I don't I'll
never write him as good as Alan Moore
but nobody said you had to
that's very true
um in an interview with a guardian he uh
he he revealed some of his thoughts
about the culture and these are the
comic book entertainment
um he is quoted by saying I said around
2011 that I thought it had serious and
worrying implications for the future if
millions of adults were queuing up to
see Batman movies because that kind of
infant infantilization that urged
towards simpler times simpler realities
can very often be a precursor to fascism
uh he continued uh hundreds of thousands
of adults are lining up to see
characters in situations that have been
created to entertain the 12 year old
boys and it was always boys of 50 years
ago I didn't really think that
superheroes were not fair I think this
was a misunderstanding born of what
happened in the 80s to which I must put
my hand up to a considerable share of
the blame it was not intentional when
things like Watchmen were first
appearing there were an awful lot of
headlines saying Comics have grown up I
tend to think that no Comics hadn't
grown up there were a few titles that
were more adult than people were used to
but the majority of comics titles were
pretty much the same as they'd ever been
it wasn't Comics growing up I think it
was Mother Comics meaning the emotional
age of the audience coming the other way
and he talks about you know the the V
for Vendetta mask that David Lloyd had
drawn um how it become adopted by
anti-state protests around the world
um he says I can't endorse everything
that people who take that mask as an
icon might do in the future of course
I'm hard to see that it's been adopted
by protest movements so widely around
the world because we do need protest
movements now probably more than we've
ever done before
so Alan Moore has feelings about
comics and how they seem at least to him
to be on ramped towards
something loose emblic fascism yes
um and in his mind the the the Donald
Trump election 2016 coincided with
superhero movies moving to the top of
the worldwide box office
and that that want for a simpler time
listen man anything Alan Moore says
um that's not like hate speech and the
guy don't do that
I I'm [ __ ] give him all the room he
wants this guy wrote [ __ ] Watchmen
for heaven's sakes
so
this is somebody who
laid the track of what the culture
became and if he sees something
troubling
I ain't gonna argue that all being said
I like all that [ __ ] I don't know what
it says about me
and I don't feel like a fascist I don't
think he said I was one no I'm not
taking offense or anything but
um that's interesting yeah you know I I
tend to feel the same way that I feel
when people say that
video games lead people down the road of
violence that rock and roll or rap
musically people down the road of
anything the idea that media can prompt
a person to do a thing
um which is something that I don't
really hold faith in
um I do think that people who were
predisposed to a certain direction can
find Harmony in occasionally the kind of
content they they do take on board
um it can it can it can be a bit of an
echo chamber and the more things you put
in that Echo chamber that sound the way
you want them to sound the easier it is
for you to believe that but if that was
the case there would be a lot more
fascists and there are more than there
should be but still you know there would
be a lot more you know random gun
violence there's more than there should
be but still
um based on the amount of people that
buy video games like you know Call of
Duty or Modern Warfare or Halo or
Destiny or any of that sort of thing so
it's like
I don't think I don't think correlation
and causality are the same thing
uh in chat Stanley says this show is
making people infants thank you Stanley
Evan Fowler says to be fair Alan Moore
this is a guy who has watched people
celebrate Rorschach and Veet Adrian vike
rather and completely missed the point
of his work so he's a little sensitive I
mean they're right about that for sure
man like people some people love
Rorschach and it was like
that's you ain't meant to be a good guy
like he ain't a bad guy but like you
know okay kind of point was there were
no Heroes amongst the heroes um and then
this one made me chuckle one last
comment from mean Dave sometimes
the simplest jokes
are the best Mark he writes Alan Moore
wants Alan less
wow you know what I'm saying respect
what's game recognizing game man
oh Batman's here what you got I'll say
this
um I read a thing not too long ago about
uh how people feel about Darth Vader now
and how he's this beloved character it
was around when Obi-Wan came out
and I read a whole thing about how Dave
filoni eviscerated that
meaning like Darth Vader is not the guy
you he's not the hero he's not the one
you want to Aspire to be
the way that people have made him iconic
so I I think kind of to piggyback on
what Mark said I think
you know Star Wars was created
and Darth Vader is
good guys wear white bad guys wear black
Darth Vader is the baddest of the bad
guys I think people can see in media any
media whatever it is they want to see
you know I don't know if necessarily
uh
you know there is a direct correlation
all ups and yeah all UPS in chat just
said Darth Vader is literally a school
shooter
never really thought about that
yeah I mean it's it's Darth Vader's the
weird one the weird somewhat outlier
because it is the story of redemption it
is ultimately the story of you know can
Anakin Skywalker be redeemed from his
evil actions and so if you take all six
movies in total then yeah here's a good
kid who kind of goes bad because of Any
number of reasons none of which seems to
be internal but many of which seem to be
somewhat extra
um like yeah he was an angry kid but all
of the hammer in the tongues of the
world and sort of welded and forged it
into who Darth Vader is but the story
ends when he kills the emperor the story
ends when he saves his son the story
ends when he sacrifices himself and
because the entire story is I still
think there's good within him and I'm
not going to give up on it yet and so
he's got to be that and he's 100
fullback he goes full of dark in the
stars all the time but it's not about
that
um and so it's yeah like we we see in
our media the things we want to see in
our media occasionally despite the fact
that the greatest intentions were
different you know and for example see
all the people who thought that
homelander was the good guy
um and then discovered oh wait
oh
I just why did you make him the bit no
he was always the bad guy he was it was
always about that it was always about
fascism is always about like borderline
Nazism is always about power corrupting
and the guy with the most power is the
most corrupted if you didn't see that
it's not the works fault it's your fault
I mean and for for whatever for the
record
you don't I like I always like Darth
Vader I was seven years old when I saw
Star Wars I liked Darth Vader my whole
life even before they were like here's
this [ __ ]
meet cute backstory where he's bitching
about his hand and [ __ ]
um and it never once made me want to do
anything remotely anti-social
um you know
I I can enjoy a movie without wanting to
act it out or reenact it out I mean in
fact I Saw movies and I did but you know
how they're like people see movies and
they'll want to [ __ ] replicate the
behavior they're absolutely right Mark I
Saw movies and I wanted to make movies
never once was I like I want to blow up
the Death Star I want to [ __ ] fight
in a Road House what a weird pull
um I thought you'd be bigger
yeah or I never wanted to hang out with
a Robin Hood Fox
um these are all fictional stories
Banff um
you didn't want to hang out with the
Robin Hood Fox
I did I was just I was trying to win the
argument I did yes you caught me they
were supposed to be on my side don't
[ __ ] shade me like that in front of
the audience of course I wanted to know
the Robin Hood Fox as the kindest Robin
Hood in the movies
my uh my Disney plus Avatar is the Robin
Hood Fox because that's
who voiced that guy
I don't know but you know who loves that
guy
ladies love that guy
like the internet is deep and thick with
sexy Fox Robin Hood [ __ ] yeah cause he
[ __ ] man you could tell that fox [ __ ]
yes as a [ __ ] go eat your [ __ ]
for hours before before he ever shows
you his lipstick
[Laughter]
Robin Hood and little John walking
through the forest
Lolly
golly what a day
it's uh the voice is Brian Bedford a uh
a British actor
Brian Bedford who played the [ __ ]
you know uh hawk guy and [ __ ] Flash
Gordon that's Brian blessed thank God
new tricks
I guess it's like being the Ides of Mark
Olson and Nixon
oh is that right yeah I don't uh
it does not look I mean it looks like he
had a good kind of theater stage career
uh but not a lot of crazy
uh
crazy
um
other voice roles so if you want more
sexy Fox voice uh don't go looking for
it anywhere but Disney Robin Hood yeah
you ain't kidding at this point maybe
just find somebody who's good at that
algorithm [ __ ] and just pump in all of
the The Voices All His Voice work from
Disney's Robin Hood and then make him
say dirty [ __ ]
um I'm
I'm give me that Disney Channel sure
do Disney plus after dark and when your
host is the Robin Hood Fox and he just
talks smack and [ __ ] he's like of course
I'd eat your [ __ ] for hours I'm Robin
Hood I lift the clitoral hood that's why
they call me Hood
Kelly ho
um I bet you when you tuned into the
show tonight kids what do you think my
mom was going to say clitoral hood
my favorite Batman character to 90 of
the audience don't even know what that
is please look it up and do your best to
find it kids
um
well apparently Brian has Brian has the
according to DJ Kento wow this dude
apparently has the second most Tony
nominations of all time
no [ __ ]
crazy like a fox crazy like a [ __ ]
Fox
um all right
uh Loki and the Multiverse Madness
writer is tackling Secret Wars
Michael Waldron is uh is in line for
another high profile novel property as
sources have said that he is set to
write Avengers Secret Wars from Marvel
Studios
so he's writing script for the Russo
brothers because there's no way the
Russo Brothers don't make that movie
no way no way to let another person just
slide on in
they've said many times they're like
we'd come back for Secret Wars
is happening draw your own conclusions
kids
fair enough
Kevin Smith said it here comicbook.com
write some articles about that that's
conjecture peer conjecture I don't know
[ __ ] but if I was a betting man
that's what I've been if I was a betting
man if I went to the horse track and
wanted to bet on a horse named clitoral
hood
that horse would run
all day long I got the horse right here
his name is Paul Revere and there's a
guy that says that the weather is clear
again
can do this guy says the horse can do
if he says those can do
can do
can do first time I ever heard that song
was in the Richard Dreyfuss movie Let It
Ride
oh my God I love that movie and I don't
even know why other than it's so [ __ ]
sharp it's a great movie and when I
first started working at rst video the
video store depicted in clerks as well
as clerks three still in theaters
playing at the smodcast castle Cinemas
available on home video this week I
believe it starts streaming on the 15th
or something like that
um
the uh wait what were we talking about
there's so much [ __ ] intro I forgot
let it ride
when I worked at rst video
uh first week we got three copies of let
it ride in now you've seen the size in
this place we would get three copies of
[ __ ] like Young Guns or Young Guns too
that would make sense three copies of
Let It Ride we did not make our money
back the ROI on three copies each one
was rented like 15 times and stuff one
copy would have put us in profit but I
was always baffled by that I was like
who the [ __ ] orders three let it rise
and it was Rajiv topper Mr Topper's kid
I still rip them about all the time I'm
like three let it rides well you [ __ ]
sucking Richard dreyfuss's Dick
he really liked Jennifer Tilly he really
liked Jennifer too Rajiv said he was not
sucking Richard dreyfus's Dick so it
wasn't that Mark no he didn't have a
close encounter of the driver's kind oh
shut the [ __ ] show down
she got hit the [ __ ] shut the entire
internet down for the night because the
best joke
anyone's gonna make for the next 24
hours is just made by that [ __ ] guy
right there
oh that was good [ __ ] them wait man that
came right out your jaws wow just like
that
if you see if I if I was on the money
I'd call them dick drivers that's true
Dicky Dreyfus Dicky d
ude Dicky d man [ __ ] uh
God damn
that was good
I'm gonna analyze that for the next few
hours I'm sorry yours my friend yes
Michael Waldron is writing
um the note director has been named for
Secret Wars unlike the Kang Dynasty
which Daniel Ben Destin Daniel credit is
directing
um and Jeff loveness is writing that but
this is all this is all good it's all
[ __ ] good news man
and Waldron is all he's also currently
developing and writing Kevin feige's
secret Star Wars film
for lucasfilm oh
I'm sure I'll want to see that as well
indeed on what else happens while we're
talking about writers
um Todd McFarland's spawn film is thick
as a dick with new scribes
um he's making a movie with Blum House
and they've added three new writers to
their team Scott silver who wrote The
Joker
um Falcon Winter Soldier and friend of
the podcast Malcolm Spellman and a
rising uh writer named Matt Mixon are
all teaming for a new script on the
feature which has been in development of
Blum House since 2017 and Jamie Foxx is
still attached to Star as the anti-hero
named spawn I'm ready for it I hope it
happens for Todd he's been working on
this for a long long time he has indeed
he had been he had been eyeing uh
directing the film yeah he wrote a
previous draft of it but he acknowledges
that he might not be the person to
direct even that now they have some of
the highest profile writers in the comic
book movie space
uh his quote is if you've got an A-list
actor A-list producers aimless writers
then you want A-list directors and
A-list cinematographers
um of course you do so let's keep the
momentum going he says
done and done well Todd
come to smodcast Castle and [ __ ]
screen it
when the time is right
Todd you should come to Smart you don't
watch the show he could come to Smart
castle and [ __ ] screen the old spawn
as well always you can screen the HBO
show which I love HBO show it's right
the cartoon the animated series that was
dope remember he would intro every
episode he's like spawn
with your Darkness eh
huge dude like that's that's HBO doing
animation like years back and [ __ ] yeah
this was in the 90s I think
spawn
just one you think you're safe and a
dark despawn eh let's check it out he
was like Bill Cosby and Fat Albert and
the Cosby kids but unlike Bill Cosby in
every other way the only way in which he
was like
um Christian Bale wants to be in Star
Wars
um in one very specific capacity
um he uh he told The Hollywood Reporter
recently that he could be persuaded to
join the Star Wars franchise but only to
continue the work of the famous but
unidentified Stormtrooper who banged his
head on the door frame in the background
of a new pub
all I ever wanted in Star Wars was to be
in a Star Wars outfit and hit my head on
a door or something as I walked through
the real nerds who watched Star Wars way
too many times always knew that that one
single Star Treatment hurts his head as
he comes through I wanted to be that guy
that was it but look if I'm fortunate
enough to be more than that oh man yeah
what a delight that would be I still got
the figures from when I was little
suddenly I decided that he's from like
Hoboken
I got the figures from when I was little
I also know Kathy Kennedy very well
because he was working with Spielberg
when I did it by the Sun and now she
runs to Star Wars
Mark yeah
oh
you know
a rather lighter candle than curse your
Darkness
I try never be critical yes that being
said
worst Christian Bale ever
but it was Christian bellies from hobo
you didn't get that far then
um that's one of those articles where
you're like oh my God who's gonna play
and then you're like oh it's a joke
article right he just wants he'll be a
cameo but you'll never see God bless him
he's a good dude seems like a good dude
certainly goes around the hospitals a
lot there's a one time he yelled on the
set of Terminator but
seems to have known for it since then
indeed
um clearly and one of our better Batman
you know [ __ ] one of our better
Batman
um it's amazing that that's a thing you
can say out loud and have it be true
we've had so many Batman that you could
be one of our better Batman hell yeah
the better Batman Business Bureau
he's part of it he's part of it all four
B's
um hoping that he was going to be like
I'd play Admiral thrawn and be like holy
[ __ ] like that's clearly a sign it's
gonna happen but it ain't that because
you can pay that [ __ ] blue right he
painted him light in [ __ ] as Gore the
god butcher just which by the way I
re-watched
Thor love and thunder
a realized I'd slept through a lot of it
seems to be
like loud as that movie is she slept
through like I did I napped through
portions of it because when I was
watching on Disney plus I was like this
happened
but Christian Bell is really [ __ ]
good when he goes creepy scary in that
movie well he's like oh goof Nah when he
goes like real Cockney and [ __ ]
really scary unnerving and [ __ ]
um
worth worth uh worth watching again kids
Thor love and thunder indeed you might
have heard of it yeah it needs help it's
an independent film that nobody's ever
heard of indeed
um Sony is for reasons that well I'm not
gonna say they escaped me because I
understand 100 what they are but I still
don't get it our uh going uh take
another swing at Tarzan
they acquired the filmmaker Tarzan that
deal with the estate of original book
author Edgar Rice Burroughs plans for
the earliest stages with no writer
director or producer attached to what
would be a full reinvention of the
popular character first introduced by
Burroughs in 1912.
great
sure the community character in the
right hand is going to be you know could
be done well but I just I've never been
a Tarzan guy even when I was a kid
Tarzan was and I have nothing but
respect for the air the Edgar Rice
Burroughs
Canon if you will
um but
I like my superheroes you know
with masks and capes and stuff have a
whole universe
I know he's got like Jane and [ __ ] but
I I ain't [ __ ] on it good good for
them but that doesn't excite me in the
least and then hearing that they're like
we're going to Modern invent and
reinvent it makes me even less
excited they just did a pretty good one
recently with uh
what's his name scarsgard Alexander
Skarsgard yeah in 2016.
but this uh yeah it's just you know this
seems like
people think he's got the longevity of a
Batman and you know I ain't saying like
it's over give it up and everybody have
at it do what you want but I lost
interest in Tarzan a long time ago yeah
I mean the the reason to do it
is because people recognize the name
Tarzan and that's probably about it but
you know there are there are some
characters some ideas that you know what
we can all just kind of as a society
decide like you know what we're good
we don't really need another rich white
dude who goes to the journal and learn
to juggle [ __ ] and then decides to come
back out but he's too jungleified to
sink back into the modern world sure
whatever
what about Greystone Kev I love
Graystone but that's that movie's
[ __ ] what 30 years old by now yeah
not more Greystone The Legend of Tarzan
that's fantastic movie but Christopher
yeah and Andy McDowell but she was
voiced by Glenn Close
um
anyway anyway you're getting more Tarzan
kids you know what I have to say to that
Mark
ah
thank you oh Carol Burnett there for a
second gonna tug my hair at my
grandmother
welcome to the fat man beyond the old
timey Radio Hour
this next news story is brought to you
by Patriot Brian cigarettes if you're a
real American
um our last story of the day is that uh
Depp and Skarsgard difference cars guard
not the depth you think of are sinking
their teeth into Robert eggers's
Nosferatu film
Robert Eggers who made
um the north the northmen most recently
um and then he then the lighthouse
before that
um is making it with Lily Rose Depp and
Bill Skarsgard and Bill Skarsgard
um she's wonderful I mean I'm a little
biased she's a OG yoga hoser indeed she
was in the cast of Tusk Mark so she'll
probably be back for tusks
the sequel coming 24.
um but she's wonderful actress I'm
always happy to see her pop up and stuff
um I'm curious about this thing she did
on HBO with the weekend and and uh Barry
Levinson's Community
Idol I think it is yeah yeah
um but uh I'm always happy for her she's
such a good kid
um so that's awesome [ __ ] yeah I mean
I'll see that some Nosferatu action he's
perfect casting [ __ ] very much so yeah I
mean he's clearly playing at the
Transylvania vampire and she's blamely
haunted young woman in 19th century
Germany
um stop I said Transylvanian vampire you
know if you really want to catch my
attention reverse those roles
she's the vampire he's the lady
do it
Robin Eggers this is for you I mean you
know I'm in either way man you had me at
Lily Rose Depp
as I figured I might I feel I'm not
gonna say I feel I I do feel responsible
largely responsible for
like her starting in the movies she she
was not thinking about that at all and
then we did Tuscan yoga hosers and now
that's her world
um so I take a little like point of
Pride when I see her doing stuff I'm
like right on man go get it
all right so that's the end of the news
see on the news there were a couple of
trailers we could talk about
um which don't quite hit reviews
um because they're not like deep into it
but
knew what kind of forever trailer
dropped yeah that was great man a lot
more Namor
a lot more neighborhood name more
[ __ ] with the wings on his feet how
[ __ ] awesome was that I mean I've
been I've been reading those comics for
years and I never saw it in my head that
way but they literally haven't buzzing
like a [ __ ] like a b like this is or
a hummingbird and [ __ ] it's [ __ ] dope
hell yeah hell yeah I'm ready I'm ready
for that movie I heard on the internet
somebody was saying that like
uh somebody had a theory that killmonger
is coming back which I was like
killmonger's dead but they were like
remember that monologue about throw me
in the ocean with my ancestors and stuff
and like who's in the ocean I'm like
Namor
what if that was what if they found a
way to bring him back and [ __ ] oh
oh I can't wait to see that movie uh
Ryan coogler [ __ ] genius so
that movie looks dope and they've
already now shown us that uh the Black
Panther looks like uh
Looks Like A Lady
I'm pretty sure it's sure pretty sure
you that it sure well for the fact that
it could be Angela Bassett as well
there's there's a lot of ladies in there
true that's true do you think that's how
they're gonna run it like a little
mystery the whole movie and be like
which one's in the suit
um I mean I I I hope not except that I
know they're going to run as a mystery
now because it could be surely for sure
it could be Okoye for sure it could be
Nakia for sure it could be Queen ramonda
for sure any of those four women could
totally be there and Michaela Cole is
playing another wakandan
um you know agent of the of the dorm
Elijah she could be like we have we have
a a smorgasbord
of uh potential powerful women who could
get in that suit
it's probably not Ruby Williams because
she's been she's got her own
yeah she got it the ironheart suit the
Iron Heart suit but uh but yeah my my
one my one sadness about this movie is
that I will be in the United Kingdom on
opening day
um at a convention in uh in Arrow gate
called thought bubble listen to your
first world [ __ ] problems I know I'm
gonna be traveling internally I won't be
as America for the opening day of the
Black Panther movie
I'm sorry uh well I'll tell you what
what day is it open November 11th
foreign
let me look I'm curious November 11th
I am
on November 10th I'm at Kansas City the
Midland
doing clerks three the convenience tour
and November 10th
uh that's November 10th November 12th
I'm at Oklahoma City but right now
November 11th I got nothing
so maybe I fly back to smile Castle
Cinemas
for black panther wakanda forever
post screenings for the very first merry
Marvel movie Society screenings
yes
but uh but yeah no I will see it in the
UK I will hopefully see it before I go
I'm trying my best you know right over
there
flash dancing in the corner I am that's
what I'm going to be doing
um all right uh and there's one more
trailer that maybe we talk about maybe
we don't you tell me how you feel about
Super Mario
I didn't see it that trail is up
trailer's up I also did not see the
trailer for Glass Onion I think they put
a trailer up today
um yeah there was one up earlier and
then they announced that tickets were on
sale for The Limited theatrical run that
they're doing knives out two was it
called glass onion knives out super just
Knives Out Glass Onion it's Glass Onion
a Knives Out Thriller I think it's what
they're calling it very nice look at him
with his own franchise uh Ryan uh
Johnson's sitting there going like I've
never done a franchise before
um he took so much crap for somebody
else's franchise he did the smartest
thing he could he created his own good
for him I got paid for it yeah and
nobody's ever going to be like you're
doing it wrong he's like [ __ ] you say
that to the guy who does you know read
Knives Out the reboot 10 years 15 years
from now
Works in
um all right we're gonna talk about some
[ __ ] we've seen we can talk about some
[ __ ] we see and I got three things that
I've seen that we can talk about did we
want to uh do another ad or save that
for the Q a
um I mean we can do it now
um let's save it for the Q a I want
everybody wants to [ __ ] off they don't
have to hear the ads then all right
we're going to talk about some [ __ ] that
we've seen kids I'm gonna tell you right
now
a store it's gonna have spoilers Galore
so if you haven't seen this [ __ ]
plug it up plug it up just like I said
and carry plug it up plug it up
um
and that was such a [ __ ]
sentimental scene if I remember
correctly
um
I watched
werewolf By Night Mark
theater one of smod Castle Cinemas Josh
Roush Dr Josh Roush hooked up the laptop
so we got to watch this glorious black
and white [ __ ] Vision on the big
screen on a Friday night like 11 o'clock
and [ __ ]
I was eating my fake Meats
unreal Deli I was smoking my weed Caviar
Gold
I was drinking my liquid dust I had my
feet up it was Heaven so all the
conditions to watch the movie were
perfect
uh and it's not a movie of course it's
like an hour long special
and boy did it [ __ ] deliver it was so
fun so beautiful who knew that you know
Michael giacchino the composer
was such a strong visual [ __ ] stylist
as well it's unfair to be good at two
things making music and making movies
and he made a fine homage to Universal
horror using
characters from the horror ass end of
the uh Marvel Universe
old 70s characters man werewolf by night
goes way to [ __ ] back and you know
spoilers
man thing when they turned into a
lovable Snuffaluffagus type character
but he also had his touch you know that
[ __ ] Sears the guilty and [ __ ]
so they took all the elements and mixed
them up and gave them a modern spin
and turned it into a buddy comedy of
sorts
but my God it was [ __ ] they didn't
spare on the gore
certainly didn't feel PG-13
uh loved it more of this Marvel like
one-offs that just expand the universe
maybe one day we see
uh werewolf finite pop up in another
thing now that he's been established but
man it was such a good [ __ ] time it
looked incredible projected on the big
screen so I guess if you watch it on
your laptop on a TV it looked great too
but in a dark ass movie theater and [ __ ]
projected to 1080p I had a good ass time
good ass time what about you
um I liked it I don't think I liked it
quite as much as you did
um that's because you didn't get high in
watching my movie theater no that's my
that was clearly my problem I was in the
wrong venue for the wrong thing
um I just I I liked all of it I just
didn't like I didn't love any of it to
me it felt like the volume could have
been turned up a bit on everything like
it could have been a little bit scary or
could have been a little bit funnier
um it could have been a little bit
cooler
um and I and I think that that the and I
love some of the performances Garcia
Bernal is great as Jack Terrier
um the best name ever for a werewolf
um I think Laura Donnelly is a lot of
fun as Elsa Bloodstone and I liked her
from the Nevers
um you know like the the cast was all
good I just wanted a little bit more
richness to everything they were doing
and I really wanted the werewolf to be
more impressive
you know like you it look I mean look
better than he did yeah I mean it just
it looks like a guy in a suit you know a
guy wearing kind of like a furry fluffy
vest when man thing is over there is a
complete full-on CG creation which looks
great right and so like if you're gonna
keep to the Universal horror feel of it
and that's why he's wearing just a
Shaggy you know costume and some like
grease paint to to get you to werewolf
then man thing also should have been
that same aesthetic it was the it was
the split of the two I was like why not
that he needed to be some CG monstrosity
but there's a version of it that is
practical makeup that is a little bit
more pulpey than what this was there's
there's American Werewolf in them
American vampire American well over
London version of it which was again an
ocg at all but was frightening and or
like gorian teeth and musculaturity
bigger than than the previous version
everything was like I just I don't know
I just wanted we're building do this
then make that awesome and for me it was
just a little shy about it
whoever knows fear Mark
Burns at the touch of the man thing
indeed
um Rich uh Treasure Trove of characters
that they have unexplored
they instantly made man thing a thing a
giant sized man thing a bunch of
strangers who were like who is this guy
what's the [ __ ] story he's adorable
and I didn't quite get the shift to
color at the end and thing uh we're
getting a lot of feedback on Twitter
mark man thing was practical
uh man thing was practical with the
touch of CGI every time he was running
that was CGI but in real life like in
this close-up shots in the bush man
thing was
practical no I buy that but yes when
it's like big and lunging and doing
stuff like it's it's at the very least
CG enhanced right not a pure CG creation
um
but um but yeah like I don't get me
wrong that is in no way me saying I
didn't like it I'm just saying that that
it it there was a version of it that's
just a little bit edgier I think in
almost every way
um but I still took it like it was a fun
hour
um and I was and I was glad to see that
like the black and white was the black
and white was so good I didn't
understand why we shifted the color at
the end of it I was like what what's
this about like is there a story reason
why I suddenly wearing color or not it
just seemed to be let's see color face
let's say that our jacket is actually
red
um like okay I guess that's cool but
didn't need it at all
um do you think I'll do another one at
Halloween each year I mean they should I
mean if if I was am I there's a version
of this that could have dropped like
Beyonce just on Halloween it just shows
up on Disney plus like I kind of didn't
need a lead up or preamble to it just
this is for you happy Halloween
that means next maybe next time they do
tomb of Dracula oh would that be nice
um all right what else did we watch
um let's see are you caught up on Andor
hey can I tell you a thing about uh
please
I referenced it way early in the evening
the Howard the Duck cartoon that when
Jeff was running Marvel television which
was a separate division from Marvel
Studios now it's all one thing but back
then
Agents of Shield the Netflix Marvel
shows that was all under
um Jeff and Marvel television
so he was the one that like reached out
to me and was like I got something that
I think you'd be perfect for can you
come in and meet sign an NDA and I did
when I got in the room he was like
Howard the Duck and I was like of course
absolutely what a no-brainer so we were
doing uh you know there were four series
there was the Patton Oswalt Modoc series
there was the hit monkey series
um there was dazzler and Tigra and there
was Howard the Duck
so our
crossover event
the uh you know I forget what it was
called the offenders
uh was called the offenders colon
giant-sized man thing so they were all
going to meet man thing
in our crossover event
when the show got scuttled
um you know it was when Kevin feige kind
of absorbed
Marvel television and it became a part
of Marvel Studios and they started doing
the Disney Plus shows two of them were
deep into production like Modoc had
already shot a bunch of things or didn't
producing it was animated
same with hip monkey so they gave them
their full order to stop them would have
meant shelving it and stuff
there you know and back then people
didn't do that sort of thing that's more
of an HBO Max thing
so um the two shows that weren't we were
just in development like we had just had
we had a writer's room on Howard the
Duck
um but Dave was in charge of that I was
kind of busy on Masters of the Universe
so Dave was in charge of that room and
um
then we got the word that they're like
they're killing dazzler and tiger up and
uh and Howard the Duck and they hadn't
spent a lot of money on Howard the Duck
just to write some scripts but so you
know it was easy to kill but part of the
reason they told us was that they had
plans for man thing and I was like what
and
we finally saw those plans come to
fruition I'm so delighted that that they
brought him to life
um so yeah there's just a little bit of
History to that project very nice
yeah no it was it was fun to see the uh
ichimama tambien Boys on that TV
um the same week yeah okay
that's right in a completely in
completely different context in family
entertainment indeed if you've not seen
E2 Mama Tom bien kids it's noandor
it's [ __ ] and or sex
and or sunny yes
and a road trip
um should we talk and or do you want to
stick with Marvel until she helped oh
let's go let's clean up She-Hulk
because it was Daredevil so I watched
the [ __ ] out of that episode
um how I was also on tour though
um so
how did the internet react to Daredevil
um pretty well good
I thought they might be like he's too
funny and it's like he's funny in the
comics he's quippy and stuff I thought
it was adorable I thought Charlie look
that's my Daredevil the one that [ __ ]
like I was so happy they did that
lawyers in love I felt like Jackson
Browne watching that [ __ ] episode
um she's Charming as [ __ ] and he like
you know we're used to seeing the more
Broody version of Matt Murdock and
Daredevil to see him like so
you know
um swashbuckling
like the one shot where she's looking
over and you know clearly CG something
that didn't do a lot of in the Netflix
show but where he's springing from
[ __ ] floor to floor as he descends
the parking garage
straight out of the [ __ ] comic books
um I thought it was funny that they gave
him the red and yellow because they're
like this is his first appearance in
this world
um I loved when they did the moment
where you know she was like who are you
and they played his theme music from
Netflix he was like I'm Daredevil uh you
know the him walking home the Walk of
Shame in his costume in La I totally
went with nobody would know the devil of
Hell's Kitchen in Los Angeles so what
[ __ ] matters so it was good for a
sight bag
um but I I loved it I I loved that they
brought him in I look forward to the
future if that's our Daredevil I'll
watch [ __ ] 20 episodes of that TV
show whatever they're putting together
um
and Charlie Cox man
like I'm sure Charlie Cox was like
seriously like I get to be I get to [ __ ]
like and he did that in the Netflix show
but like
one episode yeah probably like you know
he came in three episodes and then
finally they [ __ ] nutted it's like
they [ __ ] took it right to the bed I
was like that's Matt Murdock that's the
[ __ ] who wanted Typhoid Mary so
[ __ ] much that he continued to [ __ ]
her even when she was his bitter enemy
she continued to [ __ ] it he could not
say no to the sex bro and as a Catholic
it drove him nuts inside but he's so
good looking and everybody wants to [ __ ]
him that that's his curse and [ __ ] like
that I love that version of Matt Murdock
like that's
and I love that version of Jen Walters I
love that version of genitals it's like
you know what I want to [ __ ] that dude
well she's been that version since they
started the show she's been very
sexually liberated under active it's
just so nice that they throw you know
last episode or two back they did her
dirty where she [ __ ] a guy who's like
you know an [ __ ] or if I could take a
picture whatever [ __ ]
um but you know [ __ ] you know keep
[ __ ] the Matt murdochs of this world
I wanted to he was so Charming I'm glad
to hear the internet didn't shred him
and be like this ain't [ __ ] Daredevil
man because I was like that legit is
Daredevil right there that looks like
the Daredevil of the comics that that I
I read maybe not I mean the internet
remains shitty about She-Hulk in general
um and they just chill they use the
opportunity of She-Hulk being a sexual
liberated sexually active single woman
as they like armor over Heroes don't
they're not Wars like Dad like well ah
yeah they totally are never liked that
first time movie
he's our guy
like legit remember the [ __ ] uh you
know she did a spread on me last year
he said about the journalists
yeah so like Marvel's done this before
they've just not let a woman do that
anymore
um and so it's always interesting when
the the coin is flipped a little bit I
thought the last two episodes of
She-Hulk were very very strong coming
off of the wedding episode which I
thought was the worst episode of the
season so far and so it's it's been
wonderful to see them sort of Crest
towards the end of this season can I can
I share a comment with you from Evan
Fowler says he's up there of Daredevil
and shield he's a lot more flippy now
too he's bouncing all over the place and
I'm like oh yes bounce blind man bounce
I did I absolutely loved that I was I
when the first did that shot and I saw
that shot like in the teaser before the
show got put out I was like oh my God
like you know they sat there and they're
like how can we differentiate this guy
and you know the Netflix version had
that amazing hallway [ __ ] Beatdown
scene
um which is like this is what it would
be like in real time but you know these
Disney Marvel is very heightened and
yeah I thought it was a smart choice to
make him
jumpy like to make him like Daredevil in
the [ __ ] Comics Here Comes Daredevil
man a man without hope is a Man Without
Fear
indeed
so yeah is that the quote a man without
hope is a Man Without Fear
yeah I think that was the quote I'll
take your word for it
so yeah no I dug it um I I look forward
to the finale
um I I still I I don't quite know what
the Titania Titania of it all has to do
with anything
um it maybe it was a red herring maybe
it's something we were supposed to care
about but I don't
and for the internet to be the villains
um like yeah no I get it
it's she's been doxed is is ultimately
the the Badness at the end of She-Hulk
so
I'm curious Joshua pointed out in chat
and I remember this happening they
teased the hallway scene
and then drop She-Hulk on it so there he
was about to like do the hallway beat
down and then she just [ __ ] comes
through the floor yeah he you know
somebody on shy they passed up but they
were like uh Daredevil
took this show in a Quantum Leap Forward
the mo she had the most character
development in seven episodes I agree
it's a Hallmark episode not just because
I'm like I liked Daredevil or I like
Charlie Cox like
they really hit their I've enjoyed the
show the whole time but I felt they
really hit their [ __ ] stride with
this episode
and if that if that's Daredevil if
that's the MCU Daredevil
I'm ready to receive it I'm ready to
receive it I'm gonna lean forward and
pull my ass cheeks apart receive it as
[ __ ] rectally as possible that's
gonna
it's right up my aislead mark
literally yeah
um all right let's talk about Andrew
just bring it home with Andrew go ahead
I haven't caught up yet so you can spoil
it I'm still on episode two it was I
like it I like it but it's you know
it's it's it's a little slow going until
it isn't we Josh had an idea Josh Rouse
of like well let's put it up in the
theater and watch it I was like okay but
we're gonna need like eight hours or
something they're up to like what
episode now they're on episode five
um I think six drops on Wednesday and
the way it breaks down is a three
episode arcs you know the first three
episodes are a chunk
um which is the recruiting of of Cassie
and Miller the second three episodes are
the mission this first mission as a
member of the the nascent uh Rebellion
um and I love it I love it I love it
because
every scene is about
every scene is a surprise within the
scene every character is very clear what
they're looking for
um and there are scenes that feel
domestic at times like the the mon
mathma and her shitty husband stuff that
her weird family Dynamics which you'll
get to in the in the in the second shot
but on Coruscant I'm just watching like
the awfulness of the world that she
lives in and what she's why it seems as
if she's she's steering so hard into
into helping build the Rebellion
and and stone Skarsgard is just
phenomenal as this sort of chameleon who
is both the the bank of the Rebel
Alliance
um and this kind of chameleon who's got
to be a glad handing
um business guy within it
um all that stuff is so great
um the like guys on a mission stuff of
episodes four or five or whatever
assuming will be six
you know it's it's all Gathering storm
until the storm goes off DK and chat
wrote mon mothma is my Boba Fett
you don't even know what that means but
okay she's The prominent character in
the show right yeah very much so that's
what he's saying he's like that's my
Boba Fett like
okay is she pretty big character
um yeah I mean it's the action is not
revolving around her yet but she's got
like four or five scenes so far and
they're all really good you know and
just the the banality of the of the
empire
is uh is very much at play here you know
and it's and all of these threads are
beginning to connect and they're all
beginning to weave in a really
interesting way
and yeah the the fact that we are
distant from
Skywalkers and and lightsabers and like
when you see a TIE fighter it's legit an
instrument to fear in a real way that
hasn't been true in a good 30 years of
Star Wars like you're afraid of the
empire
um and it's now I'm I'm kind of in love
with it
um and some of it is because
much like Rogue one we are not worried
about the force here we're not worried
about you know the grand imaginations of
an Empire and good and evil we're just
like people on the ground trying to get
the work done and what's the work the
work is the work is trying to find a way
to Hope
and without hope there is no fear
spoilers
um
does the robot come back yet not yet
still no no k2so so far
crazy I thought based on dark Nate's
artwork for tonight's show that k2s came
back or something but I mean I I think
that Tony oh my God don't they got to
steal them and reprogram them and [ __ ]
don't so he becomes part of their gang
they do they do but I think we have
three seasons of this show in which that
could happen
um because I think that's what he said
he said there were three seasons before
it ends where Rogue one begins DK and
Chad says my Boba Fett comment explained
people loved Boba for being a cool
looking character that was just
background I've always gotten stupid
excited to see mon mothma show up
briefly I'll back that all right I can
give you that you can [ __ ] sorry
everybody is a fan of somebody and if
you're a mom moth of a fetishizer by all
by all means man oh Batman's here you
know he's got something to say about mon
moth but he's probably jerked off to her
once or twice
uh I mean every once in a while you
gotta switch up Princess Leia
um
what I hope with mon mothma is she's got
this great bitching new haircut is that
by the end of the Andor series we get
her with like the blunt bang kind of
little boy haircut like that's the big
reveal at the end it's like the Rebel
Alliance is here and mon mothma has
Banks
this is
um
so uh the show continues to be the most
adult Star Wars there ever has been
absolutely you know and and that is not
in any way uh pejorative to anything
else that has been Star Wars up until
now
um because even though as George Lucas
said as as John Favreau seems to believe
um or at least has infused his Star Wars
that he's actively at work on
is that it can be you know a kids
Enterprise that adults can watch because
it always has been
um and there's nothing wrong with that
um but but Andor is not concerned at all
with that like they're very much about
bureaucracy they're very much about the
inner workings of that Rebellion they're
very much about you know what makes
grown manic do bad things for good
reasons and what are what are the small
ways that that uh that people are pushed
from from one side of the lane to the
other
um what makes them do bad things
it could be most anything what makes
grown men do bad things
pop top 40 hit if I ever heard one right
there
oh hey hold on you hold on hold that
thought back man I have a very important
thought Isaiah Hernandez in chat
says apropos of nothing Kev I got to
watch clerks three twice once by myself
in the theater that's how you see Kevin
Smith movies by yourself in a theater
and then again at the Balboa theater
that's San Diego is packed but I took my
mom for her birthday it was a great it
was great experiencing seeing my mom's
reaction
during the show isn't that beautiful
don't you want some of that no clerks
three dot movie kids and see if we're
rolling into your town with the
convenience tour we're going to Toronto
tomorrow that show sold out but you
still get tickets for Wednesday
Ottawa sold out
Grand Rapids sold out uh Detroit's got
some tickets left Montreal's got some
tickets left come on out kids go to
clerks3 dot move they just sat at a
Boston show and a Hartford Connecticut
show and a San Antonio show
I'm done selling oh
I was just going to see say what you
haven't seen but did you notice the
shankara stones had been stolen from the
village in Temple of Doom and we're
sitting on the shelf on Coruscant
in the Antiquities Museum in Lutheran's
gallery and in the previous episode
Indiana Jones's whip is in carbon
furries a small carbon freezer on his
shelf as well oh that's lovely
rafi's jaw and [ __ ] chat says weren't
we talking about and or Kevin's
self-obsession is brutal
um Rafi self-obsession the commercial is
not self-obsession it's how we pay the
[ __ ] bills you know how you're
watching the show for free [ __ ] Rafi
you know how you didn't pay a [ __ ]
dime to watch it periodically we have to
sell a [ __ ] thing like a ticket so
shut the [ __ ] up Rafi
God the internet's getting on my tits
tonight mark
you're not even tweaking him not even
[ __ ] I mean what the [ __ ] like how
hard is it not to say something
Kevin's self-obsession is brutal [ __ ]
selling tickets Rafi rafi's Chaw
I don't know how this [ __ ] works
YouTube isn't free we watch commercials
or pay premium feasts not to me I'll get
a domino that [ __ ] so it's [ __ ] yeah
it is free
oh my God I hate the equivocators man
yeah technically that's not right no it
is right
cost you nothing but time
since we're selling stuff uh yeah we got
a black man beyond tomorrow if you guys
want to play tickets and you're in L.A
what time we are we are rolling at 8 p.m
at uh scum and villain Cantina me and
Malcolm Barrett
um will roll into the Cantina and
I have no agenda other than to hang out
with Malcolm behind a bar maybe we'll
tell some stories maybe some news will
break that we can cover I think I will I
will save my feelings about Interview
with a Vampire
um AMC's new show for tomorrow
so give us give us a little taste give
us a little spoiler a little spoiler a
little spoiler
um I don't hate it
all right there it is say no more that's
a rave
um I did see somebody in the chat I
remember what his name was he was like
roast me next Kev Bring It come on Big
Daddy Ace moonshot says Kevin isn't
monetized is that a YouTube thing does
that mean like we don't yeah I don't
think we monetize with ads the show yes
so the [ __ ] was like we watch
commercials is even more wrong
I don't think we click because we have
like sponsors I don't think we monetize
kids
[ __ ] you never open your mouth until
you know what the [ __ ] shot is
just maybe it's because I'm 52 and I've
learned over life but what a [ __ ]
ugh
anyway sorry every once in a while the
internet's me it does it does what it
was designed to do
um not bringing as much porn
um we do not walrus onion says we you do
not do ads just a little tag that says
yours that says sponsored no commercials
on our stuff
like
you know what I would like to do Mark
take a lot of money fly around the world
to these people's houses
and engage them personally I've seen it
happen in a movie Once looked hysterical
I'm gonna keep my eyes at home
um so Andor Andor I highly recommend it
it is my favorite Star Wars of a long
time
no if and or buts about it
not at all
not as good as your [ __ ] pun from
earlier look you won the internet all
night
uh I I think JC is a it could would
concur
Pam uh not the [ __ ] timing of that
was
into the truck through that [ __ ]
pause well done uh I love Andor I uh I
may have said it last show but I'll say
it again I think that the fact that
favro and felony are feeding us the
uh the new George Lucas version of Star
Wars makes Andor feel all the better as
well because we're I got Luke Skywalker
back with a green lightsaber uh which is
the only thing I ever wanted and now I'm
like oh I'll take adult Star Wars I'll
take this other Star Wars I'll take the
Star Wars the Jack porkin story or
whatever that you want to give me
because I got what I always wanted
I
Porkins ain't happening is it no
unfortunately you know it's going to
just like the interfa the Internet
manifested it's morbin time Porkins will
have
like skinny Porkins is going to show up
and like you know that at some point
there's the the depressed Porkins it
just sees a bunch of [ __ ] burritos
and [ __ ] he's like God damn it I gotta
wedge my ass into this X-Wing again my
best friendship died played expertly by
Christian Bale who drops 40 pounds to
get to skinny Porkins and then puts on
200 to get up to X-Wing portans
nice
um hey is anybody watch the Hellraiser
thing yet I have it now I hear good
things yeah I want to watch it
I hear it faithful to the Clive Barker
Source material
I uh I'm also a [ __ ] when it comes to
horror
um and so I I do tend to take my time
will tear your soul apart
pleasures of the flesh
um I remember I watched that movie with
my high school girlfriend with Kim
lockren and in the you know scene where
he uh like somebody cheats on somebody
it's like the white
cheats on the husband with the brother
and the brother's the one that's into
like the cenobites and [ __ ] like that if
you've ever seen the scene in Chasing
Amy we're holding McNeil sitting next to
Alyssa Jones and he's trying to dig into
her [ __ ] past with these leading
comments and [ __ ] like that at the
hockey game
that was what I was like watching that
movie I like I got I was so triggered by
that like infidelity thing
and we've had a a
infidelity dallian scare if you will in
our young 16 year old relationship so
there we are watching Hellraiser and uh
you know that cheating thing happens and
I'm just like
well that's [ __ ] horrible isn't it
that's clearly the door to hell
is infidelity like who would do that
could you imagine
Thuggin like having sex with somebody's
brother like so la you know
if you talk to her today if you've
Tracked Down Kim locker and be like do
you remember watching Hellraiser with
Kevin Smith she'll be like oh
you know what the horror show there's
nothing on screen it was him [ __ ]
worrying that I would cheat on him like
the characters in the movie he's the
real Seno bite
he settle bites the dick I'll tell you
that much
so I look forward to watching this new
Incarnation and and not feeling the same
way excellent
um should we do our last ad and get into
a q a let's do it man let's do it you
know what I'm gonna watch Hal raiser in
my movie theater next week
all right listen you need to stop just
[ __ ] cheesing us about that [ __ ] like
what am I gonna do now oh I don't know I
suppose I could watch this YouTube video
or watch it in my movie theater next
week Mark don't you be don't be hating
because I'm a spoiled this month old
milk
[Laughter]
[Music]
you're living your best William Randolph
personal life like I think I'll go down
to the theater and perhaps watch this
episode of Doogie Howser MD you know
it's just how he had those parties that
he would have people around and [ __ ]
because he had no friends same [ __ ]
thing I bought a movie theater so people
have to come hang out with me like free
movies oh you know what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna I'm gonna Institute a card that I
give out to special people like yourself
first one's getting one Shane Coleman he
was my A.D on clerks three and he aided
the this shoot that we did with logic
this weekend as well
um
it's the uh smodcast Castle Cinemas
Stan Lee status card
gets you into movies at spawn Castle
free for life [ __ ] wow I'm gonna give
that [ __ ] out like PBA cards bro
you can't give me a ticket I got my PBA
exactly when they when you get to the
theater and they try to charge you you
pull out your [ __ ] card and then the guy
be on the counter girl be on the counter
let's be honest the high school kid
behind the counter gonna be like step
this way you have Stan Lee status nice
it's the no prize
no it's all prize free [ __ ] movies
for life you come see every damn movie
you want you can sit through eight
showings of Lyle Lyle Crocodile might be
alone but you you'll be you'll have a
roof over your head but it's a no prize
because you got to give no money that's
true technically speaking you could use
that card
to live in the theater for your whole
life you could are you homeless no
I live here did you ever want to live in
a movie theater kids below Silent Bob
as long as you can dab security when
they close up for the night it's all
yours
do you think Tom Hanks would do a movie
about the homeless guy who lives in the
movie theater with the with the card as
a sequel to the terminal
I I legit like that movie man nobody
talks about that movie anymore but I was
good flick he was good in that movie The
Spielberg movie nobody talks about the
dirt that was a Spielberg movie wasn't
it in my head it was Bob zimekus but no
that was Spielberg yeah would you
imagine making so many movies that
people have stopped talking about some
of them yet you're still
like a living legend that new movie of
his looks [ __ ] phenomenal whatever
what is it the fablemans the fablemens
oh [ __ ] that looks good looks amazing
yeah looks like he'll probably win an
Oscar and and like be like I'm done
you know what this was it
um how beautiful to stick the landing
and tell the story of how you fell in
love with movies in the first place
I mean
if that's if that's not a way to go
if you're thinking about it
but I'm sure he's also getting nine
other movies lined up afterwards because
he doesn't feel like a dude who wants to
stop making movies
Eric holler in chat says Jesus the
homeless guy living in a movie Cineplex
is a movie start writing
once again
hey I didn't give it away
just giving out gold on this [ __ ]
show just [ __ ] gold and yet yet
[ __ ] the Raffi's chaws of this world
have [ __ ] nerve to say I'm
self-absorbed
oh Rafi
I'm giving out gold kids giving out gold
like you're giving away Bluetooth pills
my friend
oh
you smell that kids that's the smell of
our bills being paid man our second
sponsor of the evening you get to watch
me and Mark sitting here doing this
shucking and jiving because every once
in a while we have to try to [ __ ]
sell you something before I tried to
sell you some tickets to the clerks 3
tour and I get yelled at by the raffies
of this [ __ ] world well eat it Rafi
because right now blue chew is gonna
take the goddamn stage man our friends
at Bluetooth ladies and gentlemen they
love this show so much they keep
sponsoring I guess it means that you all
are blueing and chewing man uh if you
want a benefit from extra confidence
when it's time to perform you know what
I'm talking about
chew it and do it and just have some
better sex [ __ ] I mean I've never put
that on my grave but then I'm a
tombstone chew it and do it have better
sex people be like well
I guess he's talking to us from the
grave uh they've got a special deal for
uh our our fat man beyond listeners try
blue true free for nothing FOC free of
charge when you use our promo code
Fatman at checkout just pay five dollars
for shipping that's it that's
bluetooth.com
promo code Fatman to receive your first
month
free
you're chewing on these [ __ ] pills
you're having better sex you're chewing
it and doing it it's all free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information make sure
you can eat these things
um and we thank Bluetooth for sponsoring
this podcast blue chew tell them what it
does for you mark what is it new for you
it's a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
Viagra and Cialis but in chewable
tablets and at a fraction of the cost
you take them anytime a day or nights
you plan ahead or be ready whenever
opportunity arises the process is simple
remember bluetooth.com consult with our
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved receive your
prescription within days no doctors and
visit talk no visits the doctor's office
no awkward conversations no waiting in
line the nights are getting longer guys
but the breeze isn't the only thing
that's getting stiff
that's right this episode was sponsored
in part by Bluetooth
um it's some good writing it's a good
copy from those Bluetooth kids oh yeah
Breeze is stiff I like it it's just sexy
enough
yeah not like over the end sexy like
Benny Hill dirty
oh yeah he sucks
chewing on a blue chew and then he runs
around in a circle real fast jumps in
bed humps real fast gets up runs around
slaps a bald guy little bald guy in the
head yeah there's a nurse there who's
like you know you're being bad but she's
barely wearing an outfit and then he
runs away in his Dick's Wagon in the air
because he's
fond of the blue chair
yes so try Bluetooth free when you use a
promo code Batman to check out just pay
five dollars shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code Fatman do you
see your first month free
Josh Tyler and Chad says I just moved
from Italy back to the States and this
is my first live show Welcome Back Josh
Tyler
[Music]
yeah welcome back my expat friend
land of the free and the home of the
brave
where everything's [ __ ] bigger and
better and more ambitious
we don't sleep in America because we
make our dreams come true in the day
oh wow okay
uh you know what yeah
it's time for the best ass portion of
this show kids let's do it you know what
that means that's right
we're here to pump
you uh simple jerk we're gonna do some q
a kids we can't do that until bamf Man
shows up I think I hear him coming there
he is Ben's here everybody
uh selected by he these questions three
kids so a couple things first uh we had
a good comment in chat and I missed it
uh but we had a couple people saying
that your mom should host an Elvis
film festival at your movie theater and
you should get Austin Butler yoga hosers
Alum to come
number one brilliant number two my
mother loves to be involved in the
center of attention so that's great
she's 76 and right now she's in the
hospital thank you for bringing her up
gives me a chance to wish her well I
know she watches from time to time she's
a big Kevin's fan but she's in the
hospital with the flu and for a woman he
sticks yeah that's
it's dangerous when you're 76. and I
thank God it's not covered but it is the
flu and I talked to her today
she sounded like a stoner man it was a
big milky [ __ ] cough mucusy cough
tiger so get well soon
hopefully that hospital is pumping you
full of Pop you uh full of drugs I'm the
Man Grace
I'm the man yeah every night I'm on tour
with clerks three the convenience to our
kids and there's a montage in the movie
Where The Boys from the Quick Stop are
auditioning for their fake movie and a
bunch of our famous friends show up and
whatnot and uh
uh in a montage that features Ben
Affleck my mom
it's an equally huge response from the
crowd when she shows up and she's
tickled by that she's like I hear that
every night people applaud me I was like
that's right ma I said every night I
[ __ ] applaud you that's for damn sure
I don't know how something this big came
out of something so small
and when I do this I don't want that to
be like a [ __ ] racist thing I gotta
how do you we used to be able to do this
without it people being like you can't
make a circle anymore so I guess I got
to do this but that ain't don't look
like my mother's vagina Mark
that's like a like a spyglass exactly
and my mom I think I'd be using a spy
glass of my mother my father would never
all right
this is more like vagina right here's a
[ __ ] here's some hairs and [ __ ] like
but oh no [ __ ] racists had to take
the coolest this used to mean okay or
you could do like well I guess this is
more like Zen right Spiderman this is
Spider-Man
this is Spider-Man
there you go but that's a lot of work to
make and it also implies that you know
the vagina is well I guess that's kind
of tight but
my first instinct
we go for this
oh good lord
um they're in talking and chat and
they're like [ __ ] it shows over no we
haven't started our questions yet three
questions he said this is how the show
goes to four hours you're absolutely
right yeah
ooh uh okay get us there JC what do
people want to know I'm gonna go quickly
grab I got no drinks I'm feeling a
little cottonmouth so I can hear you ask
away okay uh we had uh oh I'll say this
too Christopher Fluker and chat said
Mark hates us all he has a better script
for DNA
which I kind of liked meaning like you
could write all of our DNA better than
what what
came out holler faster better than he
was before
um okay uh we had a couple people last
week when we didn't do q a drop some
really good questions they showed up
again this week so I'm gonna uh we've
got these questions from last week and
this week so uh first one from Morty Von
Josh a lot
uh you've you're tasked to create or
reboot an IP specifically as a vehicle
for Jason Lee what's it about who's his
foil and who's his nemesis
so you're creating something
specifically a new IP specifically for
Jason Lee
so wait so it's rebooting a thing or is
it a brand new show uh you can reboot or
you can create
you can go first
Fletch tried to do it for 10 years
couldn't make it happen Jason Lee as a
young Irwin Fletcher
um uh I tried I wrote the script for
Fletch one w-o-n
somebody at Miramax we don't want to say
his name because it makes everybody go
but you know the guy I'm talking about
didn't want Jason Lee and fought it for
like a decade
um
I met with a bunch of people
that the studios behest they offered
it's Ben Affleck
he was almost going to do it but then he
decided to the ghost of girlfriend's
past with Disney and then they pulled
the plug on that project I met with Jake
Gyllenhaal about doing no is that Green
Hornet or flush that was about Green
Hornet
I think I met with uh whose boy did
Garden State Zach Braff that was about
Fletch
um
because Bill Lawrence was going to do a
version at one point and now there's a
current incarnation of Fletch with the
wonderful John Hamm that was directed by
um
he's been around for like almost as long
as I have
um
and uh
yeah I thought the movie was great
especially for somebody who loved the
Fletch books you know when they said
they're doing confess Fletch I was like
wow that's deep in the Run of books but
um I thought he did a great job and I
thought Jon Hamm was the perfect flesh
because Fletch in the books
like no disrespect Chevy Chase I love
the Chevy Chase Fletch movie
and and Chevy Chase was like attractive
when they made Fletch but in the books
this is a guy that everybody would [ __ ]
like devastatingly [ __ ] and that's
how I think of like John hand
I guess that's revealing way too much
about myself yeah that's fine
that's fine all right so I would [ __ ]
child the [ __ ] down on a ham sandwich
I'll tell you that right now
give me that ham hock all day ham and
Mayo right in my mouth hand in that
Richard Gere I've been [ __ ] the Mayo
Clinic for heaven's sakes so often
mayonnaise mayonnaise
only two things that come from a Fletch
movie Mark and that's Jon Hamm and John
Slattery John Slattery played uh
his uh editor oh which was really cute
Frank
um Jason Lee
somebody in chat mentioned smoking the
Bandit
oh that's excellent which is very very
always cool he always loved the Smokey
and the band he had mustache and [ __ ]
yeah
um but I think I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
BJ the bear
I think he'd be a really fun long-haul
trucker
with an orangutan sidekick
it was a chimp in the old version but
you're gonna make it an orangutan as a
nod to the Clint Eastwood Ape movie
indeed and then not to Clyde
right turn Clyde
but then you got to get back who's going
to be your Ruth going
banana head
[Laughter]
what are you doing banana and yeah she
was amazing remember her and [ __ ]
Rosemary's baby oh
you've got to have the child he chose
you out of all the girls in the world
and all the girls in the world he chose
you to bear his child oh she was one
I've talked about before but one of the
scariest moments in the movie to me is
in that scene where Rosemary spoilers
comes in and finds the kid at the end
and she's got the knife and she's like
what have you done to him and she drops
the knife on the floor and the knife
like lands in the hardwood floor like
jammed in the floor all this cacophony
is going on they cut to a quick shot of
Ruth Gordon whose apartment it is
she pulls the knife out of the floor and
does that to like
the the mark on the floor one of the
most banal mundane your grandmother does
it all the time thing in the middle of
this absolute scene of Madness where
this woman is finding out that [ __ ]
she bore Satan's child and he's in a
[ __ ] crib with cloven Hooves and [ __ ]
and she's surrounded by a cult of old
people if you've not seen Rosemary's
Baby and that didn't make you want to
see it I submit you're dead inside
it is a [ __ ] amazing movie you know
that being said of course the director
very problematic
um so maybe that's a reason not to of
course then again maybe I should just
let that go
um I uh I do for some reason I have a
trucker theme in my head for Jason Lee I
think he'd be a great checkbird
a what a great Jack Burton yeah I agree
yes I agree because you don't
necessarily want to actually hear him
because my favorite part about uh big
German Little China is how inept Jack
Burton is at almost every
um but that's what economy comes from
when is the duties going to be the Kung
Fu hero and Jack is just going to kind
of show up and not die up
so I would watch that version too
love it I would uh I want to see Jason
Lee Return as Jeff Beebe the singer for
Stillwater in a television show
after the band has broken up years later
so he's like the singer who is now
touring like
Jason Lee or uh Jeff Bibi of Stillwater
like you can't actually use the band's
name because it's not the band and just
seeing him play tiny little clubs around
the country and he's doing like Six
Flags yeah commercial ads I think it'd
be hilarious your looks are becoming a
problem
I find that one person at crowd is not
getting off and I make him get off
oh my God that's good
um
all right next question uh next question
is a gift this t-shirt lets you say all
the things you wanted to say
all right next oh wow that's deep cuts
um Chris Wood is uh you know our He-Man
himself
is is playing Russell Hammond
in The Almost Famous Musical on Broadway
and so I think he sings like I'm a
golden god he asked me he's like are you
going to the premiere it starts in
November so
you should come out and see him Woody
he's out here you know for the opening
of this show and Melissa is out here for
her show the uh Apple show that she's
doing
so when she's done shooting I think
she's done February or March
Melissa gonna come out here to the
secret stash where I am right now
broadcasting live from Jane salabout
secret state
um and uh we're going to
put up her Supergirl suit she gave me
her Supergirl suit to put up in the
stores oh it's amazing isn't that
awesome to be in a case and [ __ ] like
that so she'll be here for the
dedication that we'll probably do
something at smodcast Castle as well
maybe watch [ __ ] the episodes of
Supergirl that I worked with uh her on
uh so it's out on the east coast is my
point man so I can't wait to see him
singing that [ __ ] show ice I see
about that show
what I saw that show so the Almost
Famous takes place in San Diego and they
did a preview screening like run in San
Diego it was before Chris was part of
the cast uh how was it it was really
good and we went because Almost Famous
is Jen's favorite movie so I actually
the way that I proposed to her
four and a half years ago now uh was I
rented out the Vista theater and I told
her that my friend who runs the
programming there got a print of Almost
Famous and needed her to needed us to QC
it so that
um
because he wasn't sure it was an actual
film print maybe there's a scene missing
or something so she and I went there in
the morning watched Almost Famous on the
big screen and I had tagged the end of
the movie with a video I cut
with all of our favorite
scenes from movies and like we had gone
and seen Winter Soldier together and all
the stuff that we had done together and
instead of running the credits under Led
Zeppelin's Tangerine it was plimsel's
oldest story in the world
oh from valley girl so from valley girl
because that's like the Our Song and uh
and that's how I proposed so then why is
that your song
so she was um
Jen was we had met and dated a little
bit years and years ago and then on the
night of the Thor 2 premiere it was
raining in Hollywood Hollywood Boulevard
was shut down and so she went and sat at
the top of the Hollywood and Highland
Mall and watched the Thor 2 premiere
from up there
and was like I need to find a guy who's
willing to sit in dirty Hollywood with
me in the rain and watch movie stuff and
not complain and she and she was
listening to that song on her iPod
and she's like oh my God that's JC
and that's how that's how it all right
and that's when she accepted Christ into
her life
he's my rock that's the oldest story in
the world
so anyway so I've seen it you should go
see it it's fun
Tim browsing and chat said I wish JC
would propose to me
I don't think I can do that
Christian non-kin backs up your story
says at the Thor 2 premiere it was
raining everywhere
everywhere else
um all right question number question
number two uh digital puppet says if you
could use deep fake technology to make a
sequel to any movie with its original
stars as they originally looked which
movie would you choose and why
Bonsai done over to mark why [ __ ]
Buckaroo Banzai and we were promised the
world crime league so there you go over
to Mark never happened
um
I think Butch Cassie is Sundance Kid
but they made a sequel Butch and
Sundance the early days a prequel if you
will they did that's the only way to do
it and it didn't start our guide so I
think that's the thing you do
or you know a middle period movie before
they you know wait a second how do you
do a sequel they get [ __ ] kill
spoilers killed at the end yeah before
before the hell of gunfire
um I think there's either like a movie
that slots in the middle there like
here's the whatever when we went to
Australian years I have one thing to say
to you ready
Bolivia
I got a vision and the rest of the world
is wearing bifocals if you've seen Butch
casting the Sundance Kid recently that
[ __ ] wide shot
just kiss
joke right there
let's see another movie that didn't get
a sequel that I loved
because that's the thing like there are
movies that I love that did get sequels
that which is not great like smoking the
Bandit 2 isn't awesome
a lot of people in chat crawling for
Beetlejuice too oh I think we're getting
a Beetlejuice too and I think we are but
they want they want you know the other
one you know what I want I want I want
the uh
the sequel to hunt for October
starring Alec Baldwin oh
you have my attention sir young Alec
Baldwin Jack Ryan in Patriot Games
turbulence warm air rises he died
descends
let me be clear you heard that torpedo
hit the hull you heard explosive the
impression I was never here
one ping only
um
that's a movie like die hard well
directed by John mcternan same guy that
is uh you know that you're like oh
everyone's seen it and there's an entire
generation that's like behind for a
while he's like what you haven't turned
on like BBC America at any weekend
anywhere and not seeing [ __ ] 100
October on it see the recent episode of
Rick and Morty where
um you know they're they're it's like
there have been blips and ships has been
invaded by terrorists and Rick is
telling summer just do a die hard and
she's like what and he's like do a Die
Hard do like they didn't die hard she's
like he's like didn't you ever see die
hard she goes I'm a 16 year old girl no
I've never seen [ __ ] die hard and
that made me that I thought that was a
hell of a joke but also an eye-opener
where I'm like you mean they don't make
the kids watch die hard anymore
what does elementary school for
I guess they got their own movies like
Fast and Furious and [ __ ]
Die Hard who are you remember I thought
it was required viewing my my parents
never got babysitters for us when we
were little because we were too poor and
I remember they got a babysitter they
paid someone to come and watch three
kids under the age of seven probably so
that they could go out to the movie
theater and watch Hunt for Red October
that's how big of a movie that was yeah
such a good movie too still holds up
really does still works
I should like to live in Montana
uh all right okay last one uh Victor
Venn diagram also sent this question
last week he showed up again today and
is asking again uh is there a movie that
you think is great but you can only
watch Once due to emotional impact or
memory or something else uh grave of the
fireflies is mine
hmm
cats
I will never see Cats again
um no there's there's a movie that I saw
at a screaming
that I think I liked
by the experiences is very I'm not even
say traumatic except it's totally
traumatic but I will never watch again
and that's American History X
um
and the reason why I will never see that
movie again is because it's the only
film that I've ever gone to that there's
a scene that had such a visceral
reaction from like a physical reaction
it's the curb stomach scene
when when Ed Norton kills a dude by and
I just I can still feel it even though
you can't feel it but he's he makes him
open his mouth and put his like like
bite the curb and his teeth on the curb
like all and then like yeah like they
never show it but of course you hear his
you hear his teeth on the curb
yeah like you he you feel all of that
and then the scene where then he's then
he [ __ ] brings his foot down and I
have never in my entire life
like I involuntarily turned away from
that sequence it is so harrowing and so
visceral and so uncomfortable that I
don't know if the rest of the movie is
any good or not I think it is but
I'm never gonna watch it again as Tony K
movie right yeah you know and like
Edward Norton is great in it and I think
is that Edward Furlong is his younger
brother yeah I believe his younger
brother
um yeah like I just that that feeling of
all of it like never gonna watch it
again don't know if it's good or bad
never watching it again I was gonna go
with a joke like yoga hosers but um Dan
horstman in chat threw up an example
that instantly made my blood freeze
and I might have to agree with him
because it was such an incredibly well
made movie and I will never watch it
again for the rest of my life
irreversible
gas spawned away oh my God it is it is
breathtakingly excellent filmmaking
about some of the toughest subject
matter on the planet
and the story is told in reverse
is that right yeah
Monica Bellucci right yes
um
I'm not it's not it's
incredibly well made but like when after
I watched it I was like I can't I can
never do this again like
that was tough and that's not a
condemnation of it as Cinema that's just
that's how [ __ ] powerful and
[ __ ] horrible it is man but yeah
um Vincent Cassell Monica Bellucci
uh that movie was to look it up kids
read about it before you go watching it
because
it's still
haunts me that flick like
I'll never go in a [ __ ] underground
tunnel
just it's it's a [ __ ] horror show
that movie but incredibly well made
incredibly well acted
haunting [ __ ] movie
I own it
I owned it on
on DVD and Blu-ray and I don't know why
I even bought it on Blu-ray because it's
not like I was ever going to watch it a
[ __ ] second time
um and not because it's bad it's just
yeah there's a scene
much like American History X like I'm
not I don't even want to I don't want
anything to do with anything that's even
near that scene
and I won't even start it knowing that
at some point I'd have to get there and
so then it becomes what's the point
Russell cook points out in the chat
Elephant Man bums me out too that's too
much to watch more it's true I would
love to watch that movie I haven't seen
that movie since the 80s but I it would
[ __ ] destroy me and don't get me
wrong I love crying like the other day
after we watched you know
um werewolf by night I was talking to
the kids at the theater about our
favorite Marvel one of the kids Cooper
was like I love guardians galaxy 2
because I saw it with my dad and he
cried and I was like oh my God you're
right that's an emotional movie I said
Josh run the last 20 minutes
of guarding the Galaxy 2 and theater one
and we watched
you know spoilers the whole [ __ ]
yondu section and just ball and the
ravager's funeral and bawled my [ __ ]
eyes out smoking weed it was emotional
Bliss so I love crying getting cathartic
with a motion picture but
some [ __ ] made me too emotional I did
cry it irreversible but not in that good
cathartic way more in the like oh my God
I hate Humanity way and not because like
I hate the filmmakers like Homemakers
braver than than uh you know I ever
would be
um in storytelling and stuff just
because the subject matters so [ __ ]
harrowing yeah did you ever get around
to watch any coda
no the the death move like apple won
Oscar for
is that a movie that you can only watch
Once no no I that that is like if you're
looking for a good cry like the most
wholesome wonderful cry that has ever
been crudged
um that movie has like there's a
sequence in that film it's probably
another act to give it
um into act three that's just wonderful
and like
they they kind of cried that I couldn't
even stop like the lip quivering like
involuntarily like I'm just I'm gonna
stop it I can't even stop at all they
had all the tears it's just it's
beautiful beautiful
it's worth watching just for that
uh Michael Morales pointed out in chat
some may say Tusk um that's true I've
seen a lot of people be like I will
never watch that movie again like I got
it appreciate it can't [ __ ] do it
again
um I got a few people in here talking
about how clerks three made him cry as
well
um I was a master in clerks three he
says [ __ ] somebody here I legit cried
during clerks three clerks three made me
ball my eyes out but I could watch that
over and over again
got me with clerks three but I'd watch
it again yeah a lot of crying there
Henry portion of serial killer Trevor
Dugan says excellent [ __ ] poll
because that movie has a haunting
[ __ ] closing shot that still sticks
with me to this day and whenever I'm
driving and I see a piece of luggage on
the side of the road instantly I think
of that [ __ ] movie
I worked at that guy he became Mr
stunning and then he became yondu I know
way back to our conversation
no Iron Giant Melissa hugs mentions in
the chat yeah first time I saw that
movie I was a [ __ ] mess
super old man
I go you stay
I'm not a gun
um yeah [ __ ] man
uh somebody said what dreams I was
trying to think if somebody said What
Dreams May Come the Robin Williams movie
where he dies and he's
battling through heaven to get back to
his his wife or his family uh I remember
he he's trying to find his oh he's
trying to find her yeah
she was a spoilers wait for it if you
haven't seen this beautiful movie by
Vincent but what's his name
um
the guy who did map of the human heart
a beautiful movie
um and uh
Avec albertine
um
he uh
he made this flick what was it called
again what dreams
and in it the Annabelle sure character
who's married to Robin Williams spoilers
if I remember correctly she was a
suicide and he is trying to
find her and save her in the afterlife
and it's Heaven is a series of it was
very CG like painting paintings yeah
come to life yeah beautiful movie
um that gorgeous I think probably like
life is beautiful
the Holocaust wasn't that what it was
called yeah where he had he was with his
son in the concentration camp I remember
that destroyed me when I saw it in the
movie theater
um Vincent Ward is the director's name
sorry uh also and I don't I think just
because it made me uncomfortable uh
Mickey Rourke the wrestler
which was a great movie but I just
remember watching it and feeling like
so depressed about life and aging that I
don't think I'll ever revisit that
Jazz PDX in chat says Robin's character
spoilers if you've never seen What
Dreams May Come
um
let me see Robin's character chooses to
stay in hell with his wife who committed
suicide that's what happens in the movie
and he says tell my kids I'm not leaving
their mom
I I gotta re-watch this [ __ ] movie
I remember bawling my eyes out man I
love [ __ ] movies that make me cry and
[ __ ] like remember
dad you want to have a catch oh yeah
but that's good this is this is the one
I think I told the story a couple weeks
ago Matt Million Dollar Baby I'll never
re-watch Million Dollar Baby
[Music]
is that what her name was
and she [ __ ] hits her head on the
[ __ ] stool
um
oh you just bummed me the [ __ ] out bro
I was having a good ass night until you
reminded me of what happened to poor Mo
kushla or whatever the [ __ ] her name was
wow
that's a good question well what a great
way to end the show I know Coco that's
another movie makes me cry remember me
oh [ __ ]
Lilo and Stitch still makes me cry I'm
lost oh
family Ohana means family
[Laughter]
oof good writings good writing bro
and family means nobody gets left behind
or forgot
[ __ ] that's
it's emotional [ __ ] right there
I don't even need to watch a sad movie
to cry I just have to think about not
even a sad movie Lilo and Stitch a
goddamn comedy funny as [ __ ] legit funny
movie but Jesus if there aren't
devastating moments in that movie
it's about grief and isolation
um
I love that movie so much
I know some people like I ain't moving
it's [ __ ] cartoon whatever [ __ ]
Lilo and Stitch I'm gonna show that at
the [ __ ] theater man I have a
cry-thon that's what I should do a whole
series of [ __ ] you know you Father's Day
no no
Cinema Kleenex uh you know a series of
movies that'll just make you cry in a
movie theater
you're jerking off
I mean I that's
nothing short of brilliant the the one
that I can't watch with other people
because I'm too embarrassed but it makes
me cry
every single time is the end of
Armageddon
really where uh
where
Bruce Willis is talking to Liv Tyler
over the video phone or whatever and
then the guy the [ __ ] guy is like
permission to shake the hand of the
daughter of the bravest man I've ever
met and it's so cheesy and Michael Bay
has his spinning low angle with the
American
but that those two parts where he's
saying goodbye to his daughter I can't
it still gets me
uh can I make it all about me
um I was on set when they shot that
scene
when Liv was doing her side of it
crying about like her dad and stuff
that's when I went to visit Ben he's
like come over let me show you
and they were he first he showed me like
the asteroid set
and it was an entire Sound Stage I've
never seen anything like it in my life
and he was like don't get intimidated
he's going it's just a movie that just
got more money no different than what we
do I was like it's a lot different than
what we do
um and so then he took me to the other
stage and uh it was
live and uh Billy Bob Thornton
shooting and she was reacting to a
pre-recorded to Bruce they had already
shot his side
anyway yeah and I feel like I was just
thinking about the ending of creed
foreign
yeah when I really goes down and he's
[ __ ] on the floor and then he just
sees that one Flash and his dad and then
he jumps up like a man possessed and
then a [ __ ] bill comedy score kicks
in
I was in a mess
he left princess of pirates says beaches
and masks are two movies
that have to be on a cryathon list yeah
mask is a tough movie Man
beaches yeah I remember beaches is sad
too
the ending of La Bamba still gets mesa's
Darth crypto
you're rich
um
into the spider-verse says JC tears of
all kinds I 100 agree yeah yep that's
that's that's going to be playing in
March
as the Ides of Mark yeah hey man I'll
watch that on a big screen again
then we'll see Mark cry I'm gonna run on
you yeah
look at him cry I'm gonna run the show
every time
Steve dorscher says my wife says Steel
Magnolias that too has a sad ending
Shelby spoilers Shelby
Shelby don't make it no
um
Dan of Earth says cap dancing with Peggy
never cried so hard in my life
Justin Josh and says end game Tony Stark
dying
yeah I said yesterday the last 20
minutes event date was on TBS or
whatever the [ __ ] it was it's like oh
yeah no I'll watch it from here so
emotional you know what really makes me
cry sometimes I watch it just to cry is
Tony Stark meeting his dad
um in the end game that section
of him meeting Howard
and he's like it always [ __ ] destroys
me when he goes Howard
everything's gonna be okay when he gives
him the hug and he's like thank you for
all you've done for this country
I love that scene how much where he's
like uh you know [ __ ]
he goes uh
you know
um
my old man
said there wasn't anything any lesson he
couldn't impart with a belt and then
Tony says I used to
I was uh I used to be hard on my old man
then I realized he did the best that he
could he did drop the odd Pearl from
time to time and he goes oh yeah like
what and then he [ __ ] says with no
hint of irony as the richest man in the
world who invented a time machine using
a lot of money he says no amount of
money ever bought a single second of
time
you
the irony Mark is that they've literally
bought three hours worth of time in the
movie
um but that's so [ __ ] great and then
uh Howard's like you know sounds like a
smart guy or whatever and [ __ ] the
way Robert Downey Jr kind of looks away
and says like he did his best
is devastating because we've seen his
tortured relationship with his dad
throughout the movies and in that scene
they didn't go too mockish they didn't
go too far
everything about it was just [ __ ]
beautiful John Slattery is so wonderful
to watch in that scene
God I [ __ ] I love many you know
when he's just like Jarvis
have I ever met that guy before you meet
a lot of people sir
what does he say something something or
Mungo Jerry
I always cry and it's not like sad tears
but the uh when cap gets the hammer they
like it's so emotional that the only way
my body can handle it is to cry which
it's also when I have like friends come
over and I'm like check out my TV and
sound system I always play that because
it looks and sounds amazing and then
when I turn the lights on I'm like
it's okay right you like the TV don't
look at me my eyes aren't red
yeah
the chat has devolved into a series of
movie moments that will make you cry
that's a really good read
um a bunch of suggestions although Peter
casel says why didn't you go to nycc I
did not go to New York Comic Con I was
engaged with uh smod Castle all weekend
and shooting a music video so
I was going to go to for the sake of
going and stuff but not as like a guy
doing panels or anything
uh but I didn't make it but I hear it
was great in fact I saw footage of as
all the internet saw of uh Christopher
Lloyd and
and uh yeah
um Michael J fox reuniting there's Doc
and Marty and him on stage
um and they announced that uh Fred
Armisen my friend Fred Armisen
who pops up in clerks three uh is
playing Uncle Fester on Wednesday and
that show looks [ __ ] dope
here for it I'm here for it
um is that it is that all we got I think
so man unless we just want to keep
talking about moving moments and make us
cry
always bro always man I'll go with the
emotion
oh
I'll
plug that Wednesday hosting trivia again
more geeky trivia if you want to come
see me hang out last week somebody who
watches the show from Alaska came down
for his 16th wedding anniversary went to
clerks three
to see you on Tuesday and then came and
did trivia with me on Wednesday and
stayed the whole night
he also said he was so thankful because
he got one VIP ticket
and when he met you he was talking about
his wife he said where's his where's
your wife and she didn't have the VIP
and you let him go get her for the VIP
experience
so
Kevin Smith you mean the self-absorbed
Kevin Smith thank God
we're gonna be opening Saturdays for
lunch soon not this Saturday what are
you serving Burgers Wings impossible
burgers for the vegans out there
so that'll be I think not not this
upcoming Saturday but the following
Saturday
chicken monkey 33 and chat said uh bing
bong in Inside Out definitely the death
of Bing Bong [ __ ] destroyed me
um sorry not death but you know whatever
spoilers [ __ ]
can't die if you're not real but [ __ ]
Bing Bong ugh
that was tough on me especially because
Harley carried around a pink elephant
called yeah yeah
oh kids don't smoke a lot of weed
everything's happening every memory is a
devastating era of love right to your
[ __ ] heart the best kind of pain
there Comes A Time Thief
where the gold loses his luster when
Jewel sees to Sparkle and All That
Remains is a Father's Love For His
Daughter
so true
I remember being a kitten here in that
line and being like whatever [ __ ]
show me Conan and now
King oswick he knew some [ __ ] yeah
um all right man there it is kids
with this two 50 year old men to bed
yeah they just started crying a lot
no that's true if you've seen carts
three you know I'm obsessed with [ __ ]
old men crying so
run while you can kids this is what your
future looks like
if you're a [ __ ] stoner with a lot of
free time in a sense there are people in
the world with real pain real reasons to
cry and [ __ ] you know I watched Made Up
Make Pretend [ __ ] makes me feel
um but uh you know with all due respect
I understand there's true pain out there
it is not the pain of like oh my God
remember when Tony Stark got killed
foreign
look we have a tacit agreement when you
come to watch this show we're not the
news
so we talk about fun [ __ ] that's not
life-threatening and whatnot so
we tend to leave the real world out
there Joshua and chat says you should
start a crying only fans
oh my God if I can make money by crying
on the internet oh dude I I could oh I
could make a list of things that make me
cry without me just be thinking about
them
if you're in the [ __ ] old man crying
porn I'm the only Fan's Channel
you were jerking I'm gonna borrow your
[ __ ] term tear-jerking
tears
jerking off Kevin Smith
um
cryo says damn every time I tune in
Kevin's crying what are you guys doing
to him
feeling it man appreciative for my life
uh Ricky thus says Kevin is cooked not
really I wish I could get high
that don't really happen at my age
this kind of gets centered
somebody goes Kevin's only fans would
require twice the number of tissues
people like what is that from jerking
off no
uh Old Yeller today
Agent Zero Zero Soul said Call It The
Crying Game nice
that's [ __ ] dope
that's dope man
uh there it is kids
[ __ ]
life is good
indeed
uh it's always better above ground team
nightmare has been asking me this
question all night in chat so have you
seen Mountain Monsters it's a show about
real life monster hunters I have not
I need more information
where is it
I will look it up
you may now stop asking
um kids
do you like the show
if you didn't what the [ __ ] were you
doing watching it for three hours yeah
really
uh if you like the show it's because
that guy over there man
give it up for marvelous Mark Bernardin
yeah thank you Mr Smith
uh you want to see me in real life
I'm on tour
until [ __ ] December 5th or 6th
December 6th I think is the Hartford
show uh clerks three the convenience
tour clerks three coming out streaming
on the 15th so this week or whatever the
[ __ ] but uh
the uh you know I'm still torn it we're
still selling tickets don't even matter
that you can buy it on Home Video and
[ __ ]
uh so check your clerks three dot movie
to see if I'm coming to your hometown
we're adding San Antonio
Boston's on sale Hartford Hartford
Connecticut
um all sorts of fun places go to clerks
three
dot movie for tickets Mark you got
something to sell I do tomorrow if
you're in the Los Angeles area come down
to The Cantina
where me and Malcolm Barrett will make
dumb jokes his will be better than mine
um we'll talk about some [ __ ] that we
watched maybe some new news will happen
who can tell but come down [ __ ] drink
with us drink with us don't be [ __ ]
we're gonna drink don't be a raffy come
down
sorry Matthew I don't know you you might
be lovely
maybe yeah Rafi took it a little hard
man but you know what happened the
lesson is don't start none there won't
be none
it's that simple I'm gonna say on the
side
uh suffer suffer me don't get no rougher
oh
in the words of got you where I want you
uh there it is kids
fat man beyond
is that an end uh thank you Banff man
for bringing us to the internets so
people can see us
if you love Banff man patronize his
goddamn [ __ ] Cantina
go to the scum and villainy cantina on
Hollywood Boulevard
Hollywood California where all the stars
shine
go see Mark there tomorrow night
get yourself some blue milk get yourself
you know some of the food that JC was
talking about I'd say get some tater
tots but they pulled them off the menu
JC was that all about JC why'd you lose
a tater tots [ __ ] we we elevated tater
tots we have two different types of
tater tots now
Mark you didn't tell me that I didn't
know that it's been like six months
since I've been to the kids we have
fully loaded Vader tots now
oh what the f
uck
and that were tots is fantastic you
didn't coin that phrase did you uh I
Maybe
I don't I I think I did but I you know
maybe I saw it on the internet a million
years ago uh
as the guy who made hater tots
um I
I co-sign [ __ ] Vader tots we also
have parmesan truffle at tots
like adepts at tots at tots
that's [ __ ] cute man you're having
look at you you're having a good time
you got your own movie theater
you do I can't wait till we do crossover
events bro what is the thing you're
what's it called again does anybody want
a peanut anybody wanted peanut hurry
that [ __ ] up hurry it the [ __ ] up
just come out here and do it here for
the first time I think we're gonna do it
next we're I was aiming for November so
we'll see how it goes and then we can we
can tour it and then bring it out to New
Jersey I know it Twitter at tots come on
that's [ __ ] fantastic
uh there it is kids
clerks3.movie if you want to come see me
uh if I can see smart.com or or wherever
the [ __ ]
if you want to see Mark tomorrow night
where is it again where can they get
tickets yeah Eventbrite or just come
down Eventbrite door just roll into the
roll into the game together buy yourself
a drink buy yourself some a-t-a-t-o-t-s
um and we'll have a good time
uh there it is my friends
we hope you've enjoyed
this time together 10 o'clock 10 after
10 here on the East Coast 10 after 10
here in New Jersey cradle of
civilization times it appeared by you
seven ten after seven ten after seven
10 after seven in the City of Angels
gotta go but first here's the Story of
My Life went went that's beginning about
again
um there it is my friends thank you for
hanging out
for fat man beyond
I'm horny Kevin Smith
and I'm woke Mark Bernard
tune in
next time could same
Time same
fat channelsmodcast.com or youtube.com
Kevin Smith
Jeff's kiss to all of you even Rafi chal
wow this is the cat greetings everybody
and welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every
Saga has a 10-year anniversary ladies
and gentlemen and this is what happens
with Jay and Silent Bob get old off
Kevin Smith
[Music]